Fuck.
Stream scheint online zu sein.
Huge.
Moin.
Weiter geht's.
China-Chinesen-Zeug flashen.
Und hast du die Steckdosen geschafft?
Ne, die machen wir heute.
Aber ich muss mir gleich noch was zu trinken holen, weil da wird der Hals immer so trocken,
wenn man jetzt hier 2-3 Stunden schwätzt.
Zumindest heute ist wieder, heute ist zweiter Teil Bastloss-Stream.
Ich bin auch wieder hier am Start.
Zack.
Und Reveal.
Bin wieder am Start.
Ähm, ich zeige euch, ich zeige, ich, ach, ich muss euch noch was anderes zeigen.
Schaut mal her, guckt mal.
Ähm.
Also ich hoffe nicht.
Muss ich mal was auf GitHub zeigen, guckt mal.
Wir, also, für alle, die das letzte Mal nicht dabei waren.
Was wir das letzte Mal versucht haben, ist folgendes.
Das letzte Mal habe ich diese Dinger hier.
Zack.
Oh.
Lag AF.
Warum, wait.
Was ist das?
Warum laggt's?
Anzeige.
Ist raus.
Ah, ich, ich weiß, warum's laggt, weil ich dumm bin.
Weil ich den Browser doppelt auf hab.
Dabei muss ich den hier groß machen.
So, jetzt, jetzt laggt hier auch nix mehr.
Lagger-Mans.
Okay.
Also, äh, für alle, die das letzte Mal nicht dabei waren, zeige ich das jetzt nochmal kurz, kurz, äh, im Stream.
Also, das letzte Mal haben wir versucht, diese Dinger hier zu flashen.
Das da.
Das sind, äh.
Ähm.
Thermostate.
China, China-Chinesen-Thermostate.
Wo hab ich denn mein...
Ich mach das kurz mal auf.
Weiß nicht, wo hab ich...
Ja, hier ist die Batterie.
Ich hoffe, das ist eins von denen, was angeht.
Also, normalerweise sieht das folgendermaßen aus.
Ich guck mal, ob das noch eines der geprickten Geräte ist.
Ich würd's mal kurz gucken.
Na.
So.
Wenn das einer der geprickten Geräte ist, dann leg ich jetzt die Batterie ein und es funktioniert nix.
Äh.
Warum musste das?
Ah.
Ne, ne, ne.
Ah, die Batterie hält, hält nicht richtig.
Okay.
Aber normalerweise sieht das dann so aus.
Zack, jetzt muss ich mal zumachen.
Also, normalerweise sieht das dann so aus.
Das ist jetzt, das ist jetzt Stock-Firmware.
So.
Und, das letzte Mal haben wir versucht, die zu flashen mit Custom-Firmware.
Das hat nämlich den Riesenvorteil.
Es braucht viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel, viel.
Viel weniger Batterie.
Und die Funktion ist genau die gleiche.
So, das haben wir das letzte Mal probiert.
Und das Problem ist jetzt, was wir das letzte Mal hatten damit.
Das Problem, was wir das letzte Mal hatten damit, ist, wir haben die Geräte kaputt gemacht.
Weil, das zeige ich jetzt mal.
Hier tapp.
Genau.
Hände leak.
Ja, so sieht es aus.
So, und das letzte Mal haben wir die Dinger kaputt gemacht, weil es einen Bug gibt.
Wobei, ich weiß gar nicht, ob man das Bug wirklich, wirklich Bug nennen kann.
Neue Hardware-Revisionen gibt.
Und das sieht man in diesem Issue hier.
So, es gibt nämlich seit 2000, 2021, 07.
Jetzt steht es zwar 08, aber es ist 07.
Seit 2021, 07 gibt es eine neue Revision.
Und guckt mal, was ich da habe.
China-Chinesen.
China-Chinesen-Zeug, 2021, 07.
So, Pech gehabt.
Wir konnten es zum Glück wieder flashen auf Stock-Firmware.
Und jetzt geht es wieder.
Zumindest, das ist ein Bug.
So.
Und das haben noch mehr Leute festgestellt, dass es ein Bug ist.
Was heißt ein Bug?
Neue Hardware-Revision halt.
Die haben den Display-Controller geändert.
Hier, irgendwas hiervon.
Also, die haben jetzt einen neuen Display-Controller.
Als im Vergleich zum letzten Mal drauf.
Und wisst ihr, was ich jetzt gemacht habe?
Ich habe den Entwickler angeschrieben.
Auf Twitter.
Und habe ihn gefragt.
Ihn hier.
Ich habe den Entwickler auf Twitter angeschrieben und gefragt,
ob er zum Test ein paar Geräte braucht.
Und habe ihm die geschickt.
Das heißt, das habe ich gestern losgeschickt.
Das heißt, vielleicht haben wir Glück.
Und wir können die Dinger demnächst flashen.
Weil sie das geschafft haben zu Reverse-Engineeren.
Aber die können ja auch nicht zaubern.
Das heißt, das kann durchaus ein bisschen dauern.
Aber das soll mal einladen.
Und ich kann ja sagen, ich supporte keine Open-Source-Dinger.
Ich habe ihm jetzt drei Stück geschickt.
Zwei Stück original verpackt.
Und den einen, den ich schon aufgeschraubt hatte.
Weil er musste eh aufmachen.
Ja.
Und da sind wir das letzte Mal stehen geblieben.
Das heißt, damit können wir heute nicht weitermachen.
Deswegen machen wir jetzt was anderes.
Gucken wir, ob es hier irgendwas Neues gibt.
You can flash-brick.
Die war ja eine serielle Verbindung, aber garantiert nicht.
Deswegen machen wir heute was anderes.
Wie gesagt, also das mit den Thermometern ist outdated, overrated, jebaited.
Da können wir heute nichts machen.
Deswegen mache ich da jetzt auch mal die Batterie wieder raus.
Also, wer es schon immer wissen will, bei mir ist 23,7 Grad und 57% Luftfeuchtigkeit.
Und die China-Chinesen sind der Meinung, das ist Happy Face.
Seid ihr auch der Meinung, das ist Happy Face?
Oder sagt ihr, das ist zu warm oder zu kalt?
Also ich würde sagen, das ist Happy Face.
Das ist schon in Ordnung.
Man kann übrigens mit der...
Das beste Feature...
Man kann den Smiley ändern mit der Custom-Firmware.
Mit der Original-Firmware.
Zu warm?
Näh.
Warm ist das nicht.
Aber zumindest, ich mache jetzt mal die Batterie wieder raus.
Ich weiß übrigens nicht, wie oft man das hier auf und zu machen kann.
Wahrscheinlich ist es nach fünfmal auf und zu machen ausgeleiert und ist kaputt.
Okay, aber es geht immer noch nicht richtig auf.
Das ist schon mal gut, wenn es nicht richtig aufgeht.
Dann heißt es nämlich, es sitzt immer noch fest.
Das ist schon mal...
Okay.
So.
Gut.
Das machen wir jetzt mal weg.
Das schmeiße ich hier wieder mal in so eine...
Oh ne, hier ist schon eins drin.
Das schmeiße ich mal wieder in so einen Packen rein.
Und dann gucken wir uns nämlich heute mal Steckdosen an.
Also das war jetzt ja nicht so von Erfolg gekrönt, das letzte Mal.
Für alle, die nicht dabei waren.
Hat nicht so gut funktioniert, weil neuer Display-Controller.
Was sagt ihr eigentlich zu dem Poggers 3D-Print-Keks?
Wenn die feinsten...
Druckstrukturen sind es jetzt nicht so gerade.
Schon nice, oder?
Was prädikten wir heute wieder?
Ich weiß nicht, inwieweit es großartig was zu prädikten gibt.
Weil die Dinger werden wahrscheinlich funktionieren.
Müssen wir gucken.
Was kosten die?
Meinst du die steckt los oder meinst du diese...
Meinst du die Dinger?
Du meinst wahrscheinlich die Dinger.
Die kosten so gut wie nix.
Deswegen habe ich mir davon ja auch passiert.
Bei AliExpress ein 10er-Pack bestellt.
Guck mal.
AliExpress.
Ich zeig dir, was das kostet.
Das ist wirklich...
Also...
Eigentlich bei uns kostet die Batterie mehr.
Wenn du dir so ne Knopfzelle holen willst.
Ähm...
Xiaomi...
Thermostat.
Kann er jetzt schreiben.
So, hier.
Sind diese Dinger.
Und da muss man...
Muss man gucken.
Und du bezahlst...
Ich hab nen 10er-Pack bestellt.
Ich glaub, das ist der 10er-Pack.
Für den 10er-Pack bezahlst du...
2,90 Euro das Stück.
Das dauert nicht lange.
Nee, das geht relativ schnell.
Guck mal hier, 10 Tage Lieferung.
Die China-Chinesen sind ja nicht blöd.
Die haben Warenlager in Europa und die fliegen mittlerweile auch viel.
Also du bezahlst 2,90 Euro das Stück.
Da kannst du dich wirklich nicht beschweren.
Wie gesagt, für 2,90 Euro kriegst du im Supermarkt ne Packung Knopfzellen dafür.
Das ist echt...
Das ist echt so...
Das lohnt...
Also das ist wirklich...
Das ist eigentlich fast hinterhergeschmissen.
Wenn du überlegst...
Wenn du bei Amazon danach guckst, kostet es glaube ich 15 Euro.
Guck mal.
Bei Amazon...
Okay, 9,69.
Aber trotzdem.
Das ist halt...
Es ist halt schon ein bisschen...
Also der Preisunterschied ist schon heftig.
So.
Deswegen sag ich ja, China-Chinesen bestellen lohnt sich.
2,90 das Stück.
Gut, es kostet auch 3 Euro Versand.
Sagen wir mal, 3 Euro das Stück.
Warum sieht der Streamer nur die Emotes?
Weil du wahrscheinlich nicht die richtigen Extensions installiert hast.
Also die normalen Emotes kann Frau Scholz du auch sehen.
Also das hier zum Beispiel.
Das hier solltest du auch sehen.
Wenn du allerdings die anderen Emotes nicht siehst,
sowas hier zum Beispiel,
dann fehlt dir FFZ als...
Dann fehlt dir FFZ als Addon.
Da musst du, wenn du Chrome hast, das hier installieren.
Das ist ein Chrome-Add-on und dann kriegst du auf ganz vielen Channels tausende Emotes dazu.
Nein, Chatterino ist doof.
Chatterino ist cool, aber Chatterino ist doof, weil es unabhängig vom Stream ist.
Ich will den Chat neben dem Stream haben im Browser.
Oder bei der Twitch-TV, wobei ich FFZ lieber mag.
Düdüdüdüdüdüd.
Die Simon-Dessus-Storm-Strategie.
Thermometer in China kaufen und 5x in DE verkaufen.
Die Simon-Dessus-Strategie ist Gewinnspiel machen.
Und die ausbauen.
Und die ausbezahlen.
Erinnert sich da noch irgendjemand dran?
Alter, dieser Typ, Mann.
Dass der immer noch in irgendeiner Art und Weise Relevanz besitzt, finde ich schon erschreckend.
Der Stream wird in MPV geschaut.
Ja, macht was ihr wollt.
Aber ich persönlich mag das nicht.
Ich will Chat und Stream im Browser haben.
1000 Euro und Xbox für alle.
Ich frag mich ja auch,
also bei diesen ganzen Challenges, die ich auf YouTube sehe,
ich will keinem was sagen.
Ich will keinem was unterstellen.
Aber ich frag mich zum Beispiel bei Channels,
wie sagen wir mal, BisterBeast und so,
frage ich mich auch, was von diesen Challenges,
sag mal mal, ich will nicht sagen gefaked,
aber was von diesen Challenges,
sagen wir mal, sehr glückliche Fügungen hat immer.
Ja.
Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass bei diesen ganzen Sachen immer alles so mit ganz rechten Dingen zugeht.
Das hat einfach viel zu viel Fake-Potenzial.
Das ist wie wenn ich sage,
also guck mal,
nur mal so als Beispiel,
wie easy man,
bescheißen kann bei so Gewinnspielen.
Na, ich könnte zum Beispiel sagen,
hey, ich verlose jetzt 10 Max-FPS-T-Shirts.
Habe ich nicht, aber könnte ich sagen.
Ähm, und da könnte ich sogar ein Video machen,
wo ich irgendwie, sagen wir mal,
also ich Gewinner ziehe, ja, mit random Nummern oder so.
Wer sagt denn, dass die Nummern wirklich komplett random sind?
Oder wer sagt denn, dass ich die Gewinner wirklich random gepickt habe?
Das ist, das hat so viel Fake-Potenzial.
Ich meine,
in der Regel hast du dann relativ wenig Anreiz,
wenn du 10 T-Shirts raushaust.
Wenn du allerdings sagst,
hey, ich sage nur, dass ich 10 T-Shirts verlose,
aber ich verlose nicht ein T-Shirt.
Ja, dann ist das was anderes.
Ja, ein was klingt unanständig.
Weiß ich nicht, was das sein soll.
So, zumindest heute machen wir was anderes.
Das war ja das letzte Mal nicht so von Erfolg gekrönt.
Wie gesagt, also für alle, die sich fragen, was das ist,
was ich euch gezeigt habe, wie gesagt, 2,90 Euro das Stück.
Ich empfehle es euch aber explizit nicht zu kaufen,
weil ihr habt es ja gerade gesehen
und ihr habt es zumindest im letzten Stream live mitbekommen jetzt auch.
Die Dinger kannst du gerade nicht flashen
und die sind ohne Custom-Firmware nicht so gut.
Du hast ungefähr ein halbes Jahr Batterielaufzeit
und du brauchst China-App dafür
und du brauchst die China-App dafür, dass es funktioniert.
Mit Custom-Firmware kannst du es auslesen, mit was du willst
und die Batterie hält über ein Jahr.
Weil irgendjemand bei den China-Chinesen hat sich gedacht,
es ist eine sinnvolle Idee,
dass so ein Temperatursensor alle fünf Sekunden die Werte verschicken muss.
Ich habe es runtergestellt auf alle fünf Minuten,
weil ich meine, ob ich jetzt die Temperatur,
sagen wir mal aus meiner Temperatur und Luftfeuchtigkeit,
sagen wir mal aus meinem Bad, alle fünf Sekunden brauche,
ist, würde ich mal sagen, etwas fragwürdig.
Der Chat erklärt die Welt wieder, okay.
Habe ich noch nie was von gehört.
Ups, was ist das? Gehe fort.
Windows, lul.
KS-Freak hat mal ein Gewinnspiel gemacht und immer gesagt,
demnächst, das wundert mich nicht, KS-Freak ist auch so ein Spezialist,
hat ja einen Plan von einer guten Schreiblicht-Lampe.
Ich zeige dir eine richtig Poggas-Lampe,
aber mit dem Unterschied, das ist keine wirklich gute Schreiblicht,
aber ich zeige dir mal eine Selbstbau-Lampe, die ich echt nice finde.
Zach, wo habe ich es?
Wo ist die Lampe? Moment, Moment, ich muss es kurz holen.
Schau mal, schau-me, schau-me.
Hier, guck mal.
Selbst-3D-gedruckte Lampe.
Wie switchst du deinen Bildschirm?
In dem Fall gar nicht.
Ich habe die Kamera auf und drücke einfach Fenster maximieren, Shortcut.
Du siehst ja, guck mal, maximieren, du siehst, das ist eigentlich ein Browser, lul.
Also hier, 3D-gedruckte Lampe.
Ist eigentlich wirklich ein schönes Modell, also für günstig.
Na, natürlich kannst du es schöner.
Hier unten siehst du ja auch, hier unten ist die ganze Technik drin.
Und so ein LED-Paddle.
Soll ich mal anschließen?
Ich zeige es euch, ich zeige es euch mal.
Ich weiß nicht, in welchem Modus das angeht.
Brauche ich ein Netzteil?
Hier, hier liegt eins.
Die Sache ist jetzt die, was ist denn das für ein Netzteil?
Zeige ich mal, das müsste ein 5-Volt-Netzteil sein, ist es?
Oh, oh, laggerino, Alter, hör auf zu laggen.
Was ist denn hier los?
Ach nee, das laggt nicht, das ist der Fokus, das ist der Fokus vom iPhone.
Guck mal, der Fokus vom iPhone buggt.
5-Volt-Netzteil, excellent.
Weil, guck, wenn ich hier so dinge.
Ist überhaupt kein Problem, das ist der Fokus, der irgendwie ein bisschen rumspackt.
Okay, ich schließe mal kurz an.
Also es muss auf jeden Fall ein 5-Volt-Netzteil sein, weil es ist ein 5-Volt-Microcontroller drin.
Und es ist ein 5-Volt-16x16-LED-Matrix drin.
So, ich schließe mal an.
Pock.
Like this.
So, hier, zack.
Hey.
So, und da ist W-LED drauf.
Das kann man jetzt steuern.
Die Sache ist nur die, ich weiß die IP nicht aus dem Kopf.
Aber das kann man steuern.
Zack.
Ich gehe mal kurz auf meinen zweiten Bildschirm.
Und mache mal kurz die Lampe aus.
Da muss ich kurz mein Heimautomatisierungs-Stellzeug aufmachen.
Licht aus.
Und Lampe, ist das die Lampe?
Ja.
Okay, Lampe.
So.
Da kann ich jetzt zum Beispiel so Dinger machen wie.
Ja, man sieht das in der Kamera nicht gut.
Du kannst die Farben ändern.
Du kannst auch so abgedrehte Dinger machen wie.
Sowas da und so.
Das ist halt echt nice.
Das kannst du dir für 6-7 Euro selber 3D drucken.
Was ich halt echt cool finde.
Wenn du FFZ installiert hast, gehst du in die Settings von FFZ.
Und sagst Banded-Witch-TV-Emotes ein und animierte Emotes ein.
Und das ist das.
Easy.
Ja, du kannst hier alles Mögliche einstellen.
Ich kann es euch mal zeigen, wie das GUI dazu aussieht.
Da muss ich aber erstmal rausbekommen, was die Lampe für eine IP hat.
Das mache ich gleich.
Aber du hast...
Ich meine, sowas willst du vielleicht nicht im Schlafzimmer haben.
Da gebe ich euch schon recht.
Warte mal.
WLED.
Das ist das Richtige.
Ich hoffe, das ist das Richtige.
So sieht dann das GUI aus, wo man das einstellt.
Man kann es Home Assistant integrieren.
Aber so sieht das Standalone-GUI aus.
Guckt, da kann man dann hier rumstellen.
Oder man sagt zum Beispiel, nee, nee, das will ich nicht.
Wir machen mal wieder auf Gelb.
Und dann geht man auf Effekte.
Was zu Silvester wirklich cool ist.
Fireworks 1D.
Bester Silvester-LED-Effekt.
Hallo, ist heute Basteltag?
Ja.
Ich bin am PC die ganze Zeit.
Hast du zig Effekte.
Was ich ganz cool finde, ist einfach nur Fire.
Das sieht an einem LED-Streifen besser aus.
Ich meine, bei der Lampe sieht es ein bisschen blöd aus.
Na gut, es sieht halt so ein bisschen aus wie Feuer.
Was von unten rauf kommt.
Man sieht es ja halbwegs.
Also ich finde, für selbstgebaut ist es wirklich cool.
Es sieht ein bisschen blöd aus in der Kamera, muss ich sagen.
Weil, mal kurz groß, die einzelnen LEDs sehen in der Kamera viel,
die stechen viel mehr raus in der Kamera, als es wirklich in echt ist.
Also hier sieht es ja so aus in der Kamera, als kannst du wirklich exakt
die Umrisse einer jeden LED ausmachen.
Das ist gar nicht so, wenn du dann echt drauf guckst.
Naja, gut.
Das nur am Rande, weil es irgendjemand gerade von Schreibtischlampen hat.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es wirklich hier eine super empfehlenswerte Schreibtischlampe ist,
mit solchen Effekten.
Aber was ich bei der Sache ganz cool finde, du kannst es halt für 6, 7 Euro,
kannst du sowas selbst mit einem 3D-Druckgas ausbauen.
Was hast du für Netzteil?
Zeige ich dir.
Ich mache erstmal wieder Licht an und das Ding aus.
So, Lampe aus, Bastlos an.
Exzellent.
Was ich für ein Netzteil habe, ist folgendes.
Wobei, ich habe mir gerade gemerkt, die Lampe behalte ich mal.
Da können wir nachher die geflashten Steckdosen testen.
Netzteil habe ich ein, glaube ich, viel zu überdimensioniertes dafür.
5 Volt, 10 Ampere.
Das ist viel zu viel.
Das 5 Volt-Netzteil, ein ganz normales reicht.
10 Ampere ist schon krass übertrieben dafür.
Das brauchst du vielleicht, wenn du drei LED-Streifen komplett ins Fenster rum hast und willst,
dass die richtig hell sind.
Aber das ist viel, viel zu viel.
Wenn du das durch diese dünnen Kabel machst, wird es auch ganz schön warm.
Ja, Big Jongles, genau.
Seit wann hast du eigentlich so ein Advanced Ring Light?
Woher weißt du, dass das ein Ring Light ist?
Habe ich schon die ganze Zeit.
Mein allererster Bastel-Stream war schon mit dem Ring Light.
Was ist das?
Das ist Mario-Kart-Musik.
Die ist aber ziemlich MonkaS, oder?
Die hört gar nicht mehr auf.
Ja, so ist schon besser.
Wir können auch die andere anmachen.
Das ist wieder so ein Stream, wo die Lautstärke nicht...
Mach mal Kirby-Musik.
Wenn du eine gute Playlist hast, schick her.
So, jetzt habe ich euch das auch gezeigt mit der Lampe.
So, es gab noch irgendeine Frage wegen Technik, wenn ich am Rechner bin oder so.
Wo war denn das?
Oder Computer?
Ja, ich finde es jetzt nicht.
Wer hat denn da irgendwas gefragt?
Hast du das SensorThings API benutzt?
Ne, weiß nicht, was das ist.
Keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Genau, das ist ein Video zu der Lampe, wie man es genau macht.
Ja, genau, das hier.
Ich habe gestern seit langem mal wieder programmiert.
Muss ein GUI für ein Projekt in Python schreiben.
Weiß nicht, warum ich hier...
Naja, also Native Python GUI ist ja auch Hardcore Paints Champ.
Das ist ja immer noch diese TK Inter oder wie das heißt, ne?
Dieses, äh, naja, Oldschool GUI.
So, ich schmeiße mal kurz das Netzteil wieder in die Ecke.
Also, was eine SensorThings API ist, weiß ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung, sagt mir jetzt nichts.
Ich habe mein Zeug in Home Assistant eingebunden.
Meistens über MQTT oder die offiziellen Integrations, die es so gibt.
So, das machen wir heute übrigens auch mit den Steckdosen.
So, jetzt kommen wir mal zur eigentlichen Sache heute.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, ob der Stream die richtige Auflösung hat.
Kann man das hier halbwegs lesen?
Ja, Smart Plug.
Tatsächlich, wenn man sowas hier lesen kann mit der Entfernung zu dieser Kamera,
dann weiß ich, dass es 1080p ist.
Dann ist alles gut.
Kennst du NDE 500 zu einem Stream Converter wie OBS?
Ich weiß, dass es einen NDE Plugin gibt für OBS.
Da kann man zum Beispiel irgendeine komische Elgato App verwenden auf dem Handy
und darüber nach OBS streamen.
Wobei ich das anders mache, ich streame das aus dem Browser raus vom iPhone.
Ja.
Wird das ein Weihnachtsbastel-Stream-Programm geben?
Mal gucken.
So, also was wir heute machen ist folgendes.
Nachdem das ja das letzte Mal alles nicht so sehr von Erfolg gekrönt war.
Jetzt hier.
So.
Nachdem das ja das letzte Mal alles nicht so sehr von Erfolg gekrönt war,
machen wir heute mal die Steckdosen.
Ich habe hier nämlich noch ein paar China-Steckdosen von GoSund.
Ich mache jetzt nicht den Corona-Witz mit Gesund.
Den habe ich schon oft.
Richtiger Painstrap-Witz, den habe ich schon zu oft gebracht.
Aber ihr seht, das Wichtigste, das Wichtigste.
Schau mal hier unten.
Made in China.
Meint ihr, das CE-Zeichen ist echt?
Es gab schon länger keinen Hetzner-Stream mehr.
Das ist richtig.
Ich muss unbedingt mal wieder einen machen.
Wir müssen nämlich das Server-Projekt mal fertig,
Keck WS Service fertig bauen.
CE China Export.
Ach ja, dann ist klar.
Ich dachte immer, das steht für was anderes.
Aber wenn es China Export ist, dann läuft es natürlich ein.
Das ist sicherlich voll legit.
Mal davon abgesehen.
Ich hoffe auf jeden Fall wirklich, dass es echt ist,
weil ihr seht, das ist Joint.
Moment, ich muss mal kurz die Maus wegschieben im Bild.
Das ist ein bisschen im Wege.
Das ist so Joint Operations zwischen China-Chinesen und Polen.
Bledjovski.
Also da kann ja nichts schiefgehen.
Made in China, verschickt aus Polen.
Alles klar.
Das ist kein Problem.
Ich habe mich dann beschwert.
Ich würde mich zu sehr über China-Chinesen lustig machen.
Und da habe ich mich so im Nachhinein gefragt.
Der hat nicht unrecht.
Aber ich habe mich dann gefragt, warum ist es ein Problem,
wenn ich mich über China-Chinesen lustig mache,
aber nicht, wenn ich mich über mich selbst lustig mache
oder über Ami-Holzhäuser lustig mache oder sowas in der Richtung.
Anscheinend ist das wohl, wenn es Chinesen sind,
aber es ist besonders schlimm, wenn man sich darüber lustig macht.
Oder Microsoft-indische Hotline-Mitarbeiter.
Keine Ahnung.
Es hat doch jeder was, wo man sich drüber lustig machen kann.
Ich sage ja, Kekona-Holzhäuser, Alter.
Wenn ich die Videos immer sehe von den Amis,
wo sie sich dann mit der Säge an die Wand stellen und sagen,
heute zeige ich euch mal, wie man ein altes Haus 10 Gigabit fit macht.
So, stellt er sich vor die Kamera.
Ja, hier.
Also hier habe ich K7-Kabel und ich habe eine Säge.
Und ich gehe jetzt an die Wand und mache ein Loch in die Wand.
Da denke ich mir, okay, Kekona, alles klar.
Das funktioniert bei uns nicht.
Da gibt es so viele Videos auf YouTube von.
Also, wenn ich schon irgendeinen Ami sehe mit seiner Säge,
dann weiß ich gleich, das Video kann ich skippen.
Da bockst du die Wand und schlägst durch.
Oh, da gibt es eine lustige Story, wo ich noch jung war.
Ja.
Wo ich mich ab und zu mal zu etwas zu sehr rumrage hin habe reißen lassen.
Keine Ahnung, da war ich 18, 19 oder so.
Und da habe ich mich mal daheim übelst aufgeregt, ja.
Und da habe ich im Schlafzimmer gegen den Kleiderschrank von meiner Mutter geboxt.
Und das war so ein Pressdings-Hohltüren-Kleiderschrank.
Da war ein Loch drin.
Das erzählt ihr mir heute noch.
Ja, ja, es gibt Leute, die machen Kleiderschränke kaputt.
Ich habe mich, keine Ahnung, über irgendwas, ich weiß, das ist schon so lange her, das weiß ich nicht mehr.
Ich habe mich über irgendwas aufgeregt und habe gesagt, so ein Scheiß.
So ein Kack.
Und habe dagegen, oh, das war jetzt ein bisschen fest.
Habe dagegen den Kleiderschrank gehauen.
Es muss wegen Killerspielen gewesen sein, ja.
Und habe dagegen gehauen, da war ein Loch im Schrank.
Das war übrigens noch vor Call of Duty.
Überlegt mal.
Ach, ne, wobei, das könnte noch schon so.
Wisst ihr, wann ich 18, 19 war?
Ich bin 1984 geboren, das war 2002.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es da Call of Duty schon gab.
Ich glaube, den Einser gab es schon.
Weil der Einser basierte auf der Quake 3 Engine.
Die muss, das muss es da schon gegeben haben.
Okay, also heute.
China-Chinesen-Steckdosen.
Die Frage, was das kostet, kann ich nicht so genau beantworten.
Weil, man muss bei AliExpress, äh, nee, Schwachsinn.
Man muss bei Amazon.
Deswegen glaube ich nämlich auch, dass das CE-Zeichen richtig ist.
Man muss auf mehrere Sachen achten, wenn man sowas bei Amazon kauft.
Erstens muss es preislich natürlich attraktiv sein.
Es hat keinen Sinn, wenn ich 50 Euro für eine Viererpackung Steckdosen bei Amazon bezahle.
Dann kann ich mir auch gleich Shellys oder irgendwas halbwegs Gescheites kaufen.
Also das muss so im Bereich 30, maximal 35 Euro für 10 Stück liegen.
Dann kann man das machen.
Ich würde sogar sagen, eher Angebot 25 bis 30.
Das ist richtig attraktiv.
Die Features müssen passen.
Die Steckdosen habe ich bestellt, weil das ist für mich, das ist für mich somit die ultimative China-Steckdose.
Erstens, es war in dem Bereich von 25 bis 30 Euro.
Ich habe die im Angebot gekauft.
Und die haben einmal eine Steckdose, zweimal, zweimal USB, einen Schalter, dass man sie auch schalten kann, ohne dass man es irgendwie über ein Webinterface machen muss.
Und die können sogar noch messen, äh, Stromverbrauch.
Die muss man aber ein bisschen kalibrieren mit das Motor, dass es funktioniert.
So.
Also die hat alles, was man braucht.
Du kannst den Verbrauch messen, du hast einen Schalter, du hast eine Steckdose und du hast zwei USB-Geräte.
Und noch besser, es sind zwei Relays drinne.
Ein Relay für die Steckdose und noch ein Relay mit Spannungswandler für die USB-Stecker.
Das heißt, du kannst unabhängig voneinander schalten, was das zu einer ziemlich guten Steckdose macht.
Ähm, das Problem ist, wenn du sowas bei Amazon kaufst.
Du weißt nicht, ob die sich flashen lassen.
Machst du mal ein Kalibrierungs-, äh, wir kalibrieren das heute.
Wir, wir, wir, wir testen das gleich. Wir machen das gleich.
Ähm, das Problem ist, wenn du die Dinger bei Amazon kaufst, du weißt immer nicht, ob die sich flashen lassen.
Das Beste, was du machen kannst, ist einmal in das Motor-Datenbank gucken, ob du die Steckdosen findest.
Und gucken, ob irgendjemand in den Amazon-Kommentaren geschrieben hat, dass man die flashen kann, innerhalb der letzten paar Wochen.
Aber selbst dann kann man sich nicht drauf verlassen.
Und mittlerweile haben die China-Chinesen auch abgegradet.
Das Gute ist, warum diese Steckdosen sich flashen lassen, ist zwei Sachen.
Die basieren auf einem ESP8266. Das ist ein Micro-Controller.
Ähm, die Dinger... Zack. Alter, das ist staubig.
Also, mal gucken, ob ich hier noch irgendwie nen... Hier, sowas. Das da ist halt drin.
Als Controller. Also, nicht so ein komplettes Ding. Das Silberne, was ihr hier seht.
Das ist ein ESP8266. Und sowas ist da auch drin.
Das hat den Vorteil, dafür gibt es halt so Sachen wie Tasmota als Custom-Firmware.
So, das ist das eine, was wichtig ist. Also, dass die Dinger auf einem ESP8266 oder auf einem ESP32 basieren.
Meist sogar ein ESP8255. Ja, das ist das gleiche, aber ich glaube, irgendein anderes Package oder so.
Das ist ja softwaretechnisch das gleiche.
So, und das nächste ist, dass sie über die Tuya-Cloud gehen.
Diese zwei Komponenten zusammen, vor allem in der nicht so ganz aktuellen Version.
Diese zwei Komponenten zusammen sind relativ verbreitet und sorgen dafür, dass man sie flashen kann.
Allerdings muss man sagen, die, äh, superchinesischen China-Chinesen sind mittlerweile sehr trickreich, was das angeht.
In der neuen Version kannst du sie nicht mehr flashen.
Und in den allerneuesten...
In der allerneuesten Version von solchen Geräten ist da oftmals noch nicht mal mehr ein ESP8266 drinne.
Und damit ist komplett flashen mit Tasmota nicht möglich.
Die nutzt ihr in der Schule. Was ist diese Steckdose, ne?
Und jetzt vielleicht nochmal als Erklärung, warum sich das lohnt, diese Geräte zu flashen.
Wir gucken uns das ja auch gleich genau an mit Web-Interface und alles, warum sich das lohnt.
Im Original brauchst du eine Handy-App,
die die Steckdosen nicht etwa direkt steuert, sondern die Steckdosen kommen ins WLAN,
die Steckdosen verbinden sich zur China-Cloud
und die App steuert eure Steckdosen, die eigentlich zwei Meter neben euch sind, über China.
Das ist das erste, was man nicht will.
Das nächste ist, oftmals ist es so, wenn das Internet nicht funktioniert, dann gehen die Steckdosen nicht im Original
und man kann sie schlecht auch noch integrieren in andere Lösungen.
Also das Optimale ist tatsächlich, diese Dinger zu flashen.
Mittlerweile, da die neueren Geräte sich oftmals nicht mehr flashen lassen,
weil sie kein ESP8266 mehr drin haben, gibt es mittlerweile ganz gute Integrations für die Tuya-Cloud,
aber ich sehe es nicht ein, Geräte zu verwenden, die über China kommunizieren müssen,
damit ich meinen, keine Ahnung, Heizer im Bad ein- und ausschalten kann.
Das muss einfach nicht sein.
Ich erinnere bloß mal daran, die Leute, die, ich habe vergessen, welcher Anbieter das war,
die Thermostate hatten von diesem einen Anbieter, der, wo vor zwei Jahren,
eineinhalb Jahren oder zwei Jahren, AWS-Probleme hatte, wo die Leute ihre Thermostate, ihre Heizung nicht mehr steuern konnten,
weil AWS down war.
Wenn das Internet nicht geht, funktioniert die Steckdose.
Korrekt, korrekt. Je nachdem, wie das gemacht ist.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass du es mittlerweile lokal über das WLAN steuern kannst,
aber es ist auf jeden Fall bei diesen Dingern immer die Gefahr, wenn das Internet nicht geht,
dann gehen auch die Geräte, die über die Cloud gehen, nicht.
Ja, hoffentlich machen sie das. Ja.
Also sobald das alles offline geht, ist, ja doch, bei Tuya geht das nicht.
Das ist teilweise, allerdings auch nur sehr umständlich.
Da musst du dir irgendeinen Token generieren, bei denen auf der Seite im Developer-Portal
und die legen einem auch ziemlich viel Hürden in den Weg dafür.
Also am besten ist, wenn es geht, flash den Scheiß mit Tasmota, mit der Kastenfirma
und dann habt ihr ja das Beste aus allen Welten zusammen.
Auf welcher Plattform basiert dein Smart Home?
Ich habe Home Assistant unten drunter für alles Mögliche.
Das integrieren wir auch gleich daran.
Kannst du eine Überwachungskamera empfehlen?
Nee, nicht wirklich.
Ich habe ein paar, also hundertprozentig glücklich bin ich mit keiner,
wobei ich auch sagen muss, ich habe keine richtig teure, ich habe jede Menge billige.
Wahrscheinlich hätte ich mir mal eine ordentliche 300 Euro Kamera gekauft, irgendwas Gutes,
dann hätte ich auch weniger Probleme, aber ja, mir war es lieber, dass ich das Ganze,
also ich habe eine Kamera, ich habe am Hoftor eine Kamera, ich habe im Hof eine Kamera,
ich habe eine Kamera im Flur und im Zimmer mit dem Katzenklo.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich sauber machen muss.
Also ich habe vier Kameras.
Eine Reolink-Kamera, eine Wyze-Cam, noch eine Wyze-Cam und eine Raspberry Pi-Cam.
Ach nee, stimmt ja gar nicht, und noch eine, noch eine, noch eine Wyze-Cam,
die hatte ich nämlich mal im Pack bei Amazon.com bestellt, im Keller für die Heizung.
Die habe ich ganz vergessen, fünf Stück, fünf Stück.
Hast du das neue Video vom Bauer geguckt?
Ja, ansatzweise, teilweise.
Du meinst, das hättest du dann sauber machen?
Nicht schlecht, das können wir uns am Sonntag angucken.
Da kann ich ein bisschen Werbung für machen, kann ich eben sagen, Leute,
Ausrufezeichen Hetzner im Chat, wenn ihr euch einen 20-Euro-Startgutschein
für eure Versuche in der Hetzner-Cloud sichern wollt.
Exzellent.
Benutze ich selbst schon eine ganze Weile, kann ich nicht drüber meckern.
So, jetzt fangen wir mal an.
China-Chinesen Steckdosenflächen.
Also, was man dazu machen muss, ich überlege gerade, wie man das jetzt am besten machen.
Also, was man dazu braucht, ich habe das diesmal ein bisschen anders gemacht als das letzte Mal.
Das letzte Mal habt ihr nämlich kaum was davon gesehen, außer wie es Fertigflächen war.
Also, was man braucht ist, man braucht ein Raspberry Pi und man braucht dieses Softwareprojekt hier.
Oh, was jetzt?
Das da.
Dieses Softwareprojekt braucht man, das sieht man, das ist auch relativ beliebt.
Wenn ich jetzt die irgendwie eingeblendet kriege, 3,2 Tausend Sterne ist ordentlich.
Damit kann man die Sachen übers WLAN flashen, ohne dass man die aufschrauben muss.
Wenn das nicht funktioniert, weil man eine zu neue Firmware-Version hat, aber man eine Steckdose erwischt hat, wo ein ESP8266 drin ist,
dann kann man das aufschrauben, anlöten und flashen.
Haben wir auch schon mal in einem Stream gemacht.
Das ist da, wo ich mir so schwer getan habe, das Ding aufzukriegen.
Das ist aber dann doch etwas advancer.
Welche Linie ist zu benutzen? Das ist Manjaro mit i3WM.
Ja, Mincode Live schreibt, ich will mir ja mein Smartphone aus meinem Zimmer machen, aber gefühlt fällt alles raus wegen Privatsphäre.
Will keine Überwachungskamera, Sprachassistenten für Regelungen.
Ja, dann brauchst du Geräte mit Custom-Firmware oder Sachen, die du rein offline betreiben kannst.
So mache ich das auch. Also ich habe die wenigsten Sachen in der Cloud.
Fällt gar nichts ein, ob ich überhaupt was in der Cloud habe.
Sehe ich auch nicht ein. Also ich will meine Heizung auch bedienen können, wenn die Cloud down ist.
So, also was wir jetzt brauchen ist folgendes. Wir brauchen einen Raspberry Pi, den haben wir schon hier am Start.
Einen Raspberry Pi mit frisch, haben wir das letzte Mal im Stream gemacht, frisch geflashtem...
...Raspbian, wobei, nein, Raspberry Pi OS heißt es jetzt ja, korrekterweise.
Über Netzwerkkabel angeschlossen, das ist ganz wichtig, weil das WLAN braucht der, um die Steckdose zu flashen.
Und man kann sich nicht über das WLAN verbinden und gleichzeitig die Steckdose flashen.
Also man braucht einen Raspberry Pi, man braucht dann das passende Gerät, was sich flashen lässt.
Und heute habe ich noch was anderes dabei, damit ihr mal ein bisschen zugucken könnt, was da eigentlich passiert.
Ich habe hier meinen super small...
...schmoll...
...Axis Point.
Das ist ein Axis Point, der kann nicht sonderlich viel.
2,4 Gigahertz only.
Aber absolut, guckt mal hier, Miniatur-Axis Point für 25 Euro von MikroTik.
Feature-mäßig für den Preis eigentlich der beste Axis Point, den man sich vorstellen kann.
Und halt wirklich mini furzklein.
Schmoll, schmoll Axis Point.
Matrix HD, danke für den Sub. Danke auch, Leute, alle, die gesubbt haben schon.
Ich war heute so am Labern und hier rumfuddeln, ich habe die Hälfte nicht mitbekommen.
Außer richtig pock.
Ja, small Axis Point. Und ich habe mir gedacht, zu small Axis Point braucht man ein small Kabel.
Das kann fast schon ein bisschen zu groß sein.
Oh.
Dann machen wir mal den Keks hier weg.
Der Keks steht gerade ein bisschen im Weg.
Den müssen wir aber in die Kamera, den müssen wir in der Kamera behalten.
Sonst suckt es.
Excellent.
Ja.
Ne, der muss hier bleiben.
Das geht nicht anders.
Der muss hier stehen bleiben.
Gibst du dem Keks den Model?
Ne.
Jane, danke für den Sub.
So.
Ist jetzt wieder E-Mode-Vorschlag.
Guck mal.
Ha.
Ne.
So, den machen wir jetzt hier auch mal dran.
Ach so.
Ha.
Axis Point fällt mir gerade auf.
Small.
Small Axis Point.
So.
Also, wir brauchen einmal Strom für den Raspberry Pi.
Das habe ich hier.
Da habe ich mir auch vor einer Weile mal so eine 50er Box, 50er Box USB-Kabel bestellt bei AliExpress.
50er Box USB-Kabel, Mikro-USB und USB-C in einem.
Hat sich wirklich gelohnt seitdem.
Zwei, ich glaube, ein Meter oder zwei.
Was ist denn das?
Ah, eher, eher ein Meter, würde ich sagen.
Ein Meter Kabel für unter 50 Euro, fünf Stück.
Also, ihr müsst euch überlegen, das ist teilweise echt verdammt billig bei den China-Chinesen.
Also, ich habe irgendwie 80 Cent pro Kabel bezahlt.
Du hast ein Meter USB-Kabel, qualitativ vollkommen in Ordnung, inklusive Mikro-USB und USB-C.
Da kann es sich wirklich nicht beschweren.
Wobei, USB-3 würde ich da drüber nicht unbedingt machen.
Das geht wahrscheinlich nicht.
Wie heißt der Mini-AP, findet ihr nicht beim MikroTik?
Äh, du musst, hier, da, da.
M-AP-Light.
Dann findest du den.
So, dann machen wir den Raspberry Pi an.
Wenn das alles funktioniert, sollte der eigentlich angehen.
Ja, macht er, guckt, da ist er.
Raspberry Pi an, Steckdose am Start, Platz, oh.
Sack.
Ich habe ein Problem.
Seht ihr das? Moment, Moment.
Passt mal auf.
Ich habe da so ein kleines Problem.
Kein Platz.
Okay, da müssen wir gerade mal ein bisschen umbauen.
Ich glaube, das ist der Switch, der hier in der Ecke steht.
Der staubig ist.
Ich glaube, das hier ist der Switch.
Deswegen mache ich das mal raus.
Wenn jetzt das Licht ausgeht, dann Pech gehabt.
Okay, jetzt ist nur der Switch ausgegangen.
Und das dann, geht das jetzt?
Ah, jetzt, okay, das passt.
Alles gut.
Sehr schön.
Machen wir mal wieder aus dem Bild raus.
Alter, ist das staubig.
Wen es interessiert, was ich hier als Switch habe, ich habe als Switch,
auch kann ich jetzt nicht richtig zeigen, weil das unter dem Stromkabel hängt.
Moment, machen wir das mal anders.
Gucken wir mal, ob ich das ein bisschen rüber, rüberdingsen kann.
Hier.
Äh, das ist ein Mikrotik.
CS.
Ah, man sieht es nicht richtig.
Äh, CSS 6108G.
Das hat, der hat 2x10 Gigabit und der Rest 8x1G.
Das ist eigentlich optimaler Tisch für, optimaler Switch für so einen Bastel, Basteltisch, ja.
Oh, ne.
Pantschamp-Musik.
Wäw, wäw, wäw, wäw.
So.
Okay.
Ähm, ja.
Wo sind wir jetzt stehen geblieben?
Genau, Raspberry Pi ist dran.
Steckdose haben wir hier.
Small Access Point kommt jetzt auch dran, der braucht aber noch Strom.
Ich glaube, hier habe ich, ich glaube, ich habe hier noch was.
Gut.
Small Access Point kriegt auch noch Strom.
Ah, ja.
Seht ihr das? Leuchtet, ne?
Also sollte.
Man sieht es nicht richtig, aber Power, Power leuchtet.
Ich glaube, man erkennt es nicht so wirklich, aber es ist zu, zu hell.
So, Small Access Point am Start.
Der wird jetzt angeschlossen.
Ja.
Gut.
So, und ich mache es nämlich diesmal so.
Wir, wir flashen das Ding über Raspberry Pi und danach melde ich es an diesem Access Point an.
Da können wir nämlich zusammen zugucken und, und das Ding konfiguraten.
Okay.
Dann verbinde ich mich als erstes mal auf den Access Point.
Äh, ich glaube eins, zwei, eins, zwei, eins, drei, sieben.
Hey.
Oh, shit.
Was habe ich denn da für ein Passwort für das Admin Interface vergeben?
Äh.
Das ist nicht Admin, Admin, ne, ne.
Ah, ich habe es.
Ah, genau, Glück gehabt.
Nochmal Glück.
Nochmal Glück gehabt.
Lol.
Warum flasht man über den Pi aus Sicherheitsgründen?
Weil es das Einfachste ist.
Weil wir, weil wir over the air flashen.
Und das ist fix und fertig.
Einfach nur ausführen auf dem Raspberry Pi.
So.
Ähm.
Das, was ihr hier seht, ist die Oberfläche von dem Mini Access Point.
Also vom Small Access Point ist das die Oberfläche.
Und ihr könnt euch vorstellen, ihr habt wahrscheinlich noch nie einen Access Point gesehen.
Vor allem nicht so einen mini, kleinen, furz 25 Euro Access Point.
Der so übertrieben viele Options hat.
Da läuft komplett vollständiges MikroTik Router OS drauf.
Das ist auf Linux.
Das ist quasi Web Interface für, für ihr Linux unten drunter.
Du kannst damit alles machen, was du dir so vorstellst.
Ja.
Von Firewall bis DHCP Server bis DNS bis VPN.
Du kannst sogar VPN mit deinem Access Point machen.
Für 25 Euro.
Also für, ich finde, wer ein bisschen Router OS basteln will, ist das vielleicht schon fast der beste, der beste Einstieg.
Ja.
Du hast eine Router OS.
Genau.
Einige Firewall Lösungen.
Also normaler Paketfilter ohne irgendwie fancy, fancy Sachen.
Aber ganz ehrlich, für 25 Euro Mini Access Point passt das.
Gehen auch VLANs.
Klar.
Geht alles.
Habe ich jetzt damit noch nicht ausprobiert.
Aber muss, muss funktionieren.
Warte mal.
Bridge, Switch, VLAN.
Klar.
Kannst du machen.
Kannst VLANs anlegen oder, oder VLAN, wie ich letztens wieder gehört habe.
Gut.
Ähm.
DHCP Server, Leases.
Das ist das, was wir hauptsächlich gleich brauchen.
Also, ich habe das Ding folgendermaßen eingestellt.
Networks.
Wir haben 1.0.2.1.6.8.
88.
0.
Slash.
24.
Das ist das WLAN.
Und, ähm.
Dann hängt er bei mir einfach hier am Switch drinne und geht über meinen normalen Router ins Internet raus.
Also, ähm.
Das Tasmota-Ding.
Oh, nee.
Fuck.
Jetzt kommen die Leute wieder und interpretieren was in 88 rein.
Das ist default Mikrotik.
Ich kann ja nix dafür.
So, guck.
Man sieht hier.
Ähm.
Das sind, das sind quasi, das, das ist mein, meine VM.
Und das hier ist quasi der Gateway.
So.
Was auch immer der mit Cloud will.
DHCP Client.
Ja, klar.
Guck, kannst hier IPsec, VPN und alles, und alles mögliche mit, mitmachen.
So.
Ähm.
Ja.
Alles da.
So, was ich, was ich eingestellt habe bei dem Access Point ist eigentlich nicht viel.
Ich hab das WLAN eingeschaltet, wie man hier sieht.
Nee.
Ich hab das WLAN ausgeschaltet.
Das WLAN schalte ich gleich ein.
WLAN ist ausgeschaltet.
Noch.
WLAN ist konfiguriert.
Kann ich einfach einschalten, dann geht's.
Ich hab ein paar Firewall-Regeln gemacht.
Ähm.
Einfach nur, um auf Nummer sicher zu gehen, dass ich nicht aus Versehen irgendwie das
Ding irgendwie discover oder sonst wie was.
Ich hab, ich hab, äh, simple Firewall-Regeln gemacht.
Ich hab gesagt, hey.
Äh.
Verbindung auf das Admin-Interface ist nur erlaubt aus dem Heimnetz.
Und, ähm, danach sollen jegliche Pakete ins private Netz gedroppt werden.
Pakete ins Internet sind okay.
Nee, hab ich nicht gemacht.
Wir machen da dann Firewall-Freischaltung auch noch für unseren internen Home Assistant,
den wir, by the way, mal einschalten.
Sonst geht der nachher nicht.
Können wir gleich machen.
Wir machen, wir machen gleich.
Wir machen gleich die Freischaltung.
Dann vergesse ich's nachher nicht und wundere mich nicht, warum es nicht funktioniert.
Wir machen das gleich, gleich.
Äh, wie heißt das Ding?
MAP-Light von Mikrotik.
25 Euro Mini-Access-Point.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist kein sonderlich guter Access-Point in der heutigen Zeit.
Das hat nur 2,4 Gigahertz und wahrscheinlich auch nur eine Antenne oder so.
Also, rein als Access-Point ist das jetzt bestimmt nicht der Knaller.
Aber zum Rumbasteln mit Router-OS und für so kleine Bastelsachen finde ich das Ding optimal.
Und wenn das Ding seine IPs spooft zu einer erlaubten, dann passiert nix.
Warum passiert nix?
Weil es ist nur accepted, Moment, es wird getroppt, alles, was, Sekunde, Destination-Adress Private-Netz ist.
Also da kann der Absender-IP so viel spoofen, wie er lustig ist.
Es wird alles getroppt, was Ziel privates Netz ist.
So.
Das, da machen wir jetzt aber gleich eine Firewall, da machen wir jetzt aber gleich eine Firewall-Freischaltung.
Weil sonst funktioniert es nachher nicht.
So. Firewall-Freischaltung zu.
Ich meine, man muss sich mal überlegen, das ist ein 25 Euro Access-Point, ne?
MikroTik hat ja leider keinen aktuellen Access-Point.
Leider, leider, leider hat MikroTik, was Wifi 6 und 6E angeht, ein bisschen geschissen.
Wobei man sagen muss, die UniFi-Dinger sind da auch jetzt lange, die haben lange gebraucht für.
So. Was halt auch krass ist, wenn man sich überlegt, das sind 25 Euro Access-Point.
25 Euro Access-Point, ich kann hier erstmal Firewall-Freischaltung drauf machen, ja?
So, also wir brauchen eine Firewall-Freischaltung und zwar zu 192.168.2.133.
Das ist unser Test Home Assistant.
Wollen wir das Ding gleich registrieren drauf.
Also, machen wir eine Firewall-Freischaltung.
Wir sagen Forward.
Das ist das gleiche wie bei IP-Tables, falls jemand mal von euch, habt ihr schon mal IP-Tables verwendet unter Linux?
Ansonsten sage ich ganz kurz was, was diese drei verschiedenen Dinger sind.
Also IP-Tables ist so quasi, oder eigentlich ist es ja nicht IP-Tables, sondern äh...
Wie heißt das Ding im Kernel?
Packet-Filter? Ne, Packet-Filter ist BSD.
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Also zumindest IP-Tables ist das, was man in der Regel verwendet.
Warum hast du daheim ein 192-Netz?
Die Frage ist eher, warum nicht?
Also Firewall-technisch unter Linux und auch bei vielen kommerziellen Firewalls, die eben auf Linux aussetzen, ist es oftmals so.
Ich rede jetzt nicht von den ganz fetten Dingern, aber gerade hier von, wenn man sich bei MikroTik anguckt, was ja quasi eine Linux ist mit Web-Interface dafür.
Das ist folgendermaßen, IP-Tables kennt prinzipiell erstmal drei verschiedene Wege, um Pakete zu befördern, nennen wir es mal so.
Es gibt Forward, Input, Output.
Input bedeutet das Gerät selbst.
Was auf das Gerät selbst zugreifen will, kannst du mit der Input-Regel steuern.
Forward bedeutet, was das Gerät routet.
Sprich, welche Pakete das Gerät weiterleitet.
Und Output bin ich mir ehrlich gesagt gerade nicht sicher.
Ich glaube, das ist für NAT.
Aber wichtig ist Forward und Input.
Input muss man immer einstellen.
Input, das quasi, ihr seht es ja auch hier, ich habe eingestellt, Input, Accept Input, nur von meinem Admin-Netz.
Das heißt, das Web-Interface zum Administrieren von diesem Access-Point kann ich nur aufmachen, wenn ich von einem internen Netz komme.
Bin mir gar nicht sicher, was Output ist. Ich glaube, das ist für NAT-Geschichten.
So, also wir brauchen eine neue Firewall-Regel.
Was haben wir gesagt? Also Forward ist es in dem Fall, weil wir leiten ja weiter.
Und wir wollen zu Destination-Address 192.168.2.133.
Das heißt, wir sagen Destination-Address 192.168.2.133.
Oh, ich habe schon wieder vergessen, 192.168.2.133.
So.
Gut.
Wunderbar.
Mehr muss man nicht machen.
Man kann jetzt noch Input-Output-Interface sagen.
Man sagt, okay, Input-Interface ist WLAN.
Output-Interface ist dann in dem Fall...
Das Netzwerkgerät, wobei das in dem Fall ziemlich wurscht ist.
Es gibt nur einen Weg.
So, wunderbar.
Das soll Accepted werden.
Enabled.
Habe ich gesagt Accept?
Accept.
Zack.
Und dann schieben wir das Ganze mal hier oben hin.
So.
Das heißt, es ist jetzt alles erlaubt aus dem WLAN auf diese interne IP.
Das ist vielleicht nicht so sinnvoll.
Das will man vielleicht nicht haben.
Deswegen kann man auch sagen, okay, wir schränken das Ganze noch ein auf TCP und sagen Destination.
Port nur MQTT.
Mal kurz gucken, was MQTT Default 1883.
So, wir wollen das quasi nur auf diesem Port haben.
Und jetzt ist nur erlaubt, wohlgemerkt, wir reden von 25 Euro Access Point.
Jetzt ist nur erlaubt von WLAN zu Netzwerk nur diese Ziel-IP.
Protocol TCP Destination Port MQTT Default.
Das ist...
Also, so brauchen wir das jetzt.
Zurückwunsch zu den gelungenen Battlefields mit super Klickzahlen.
Ja, Poggers, ne?
Ich habe schon überlegt, ob ich nicht noch eins raushaue.
Aber als nächstes muss ich das Video mit Herr Endpunkt bringen.
Sonst steigen mir die Leute aufs Dach.
Wobei ich mir noch nicht ganz sicher bin, ob ich als nächstes das Video mit Herr Endpunkt bringe.
Oder als nächstes ein fast schon fertiges Stellenanzeigen Review Video.
Herr Endpunkt heißt übrigens Niklas.
Darf ich jetzt verraten?
Er hat gesagt, ich darf seinen Namen verraten.
Ehemaliger Azubi von mir.
Also wer das nicht kennt, ich habe ja mal ein Video gemacht, wo ich mich über ein paar...
Seine Eskapaden lustig gemacht habe.
Und er hat sich nach einem Video bei mir gemeldet und hat gesagt, hier Max, ich bin Herr Endpunkt.
Habe ich ein paar Testfragen gestellt, er ist es wirklich.
Und habe ich mit ihm was aufgenommen, so wie es ihm dann ergangen ist.
Brauchst du noch super duper alles admin stellen?
Klar, klar, schick her, schick her, Poggers.
Nachnamen sage ich nicht.
Kannst du ganz ruhig schicken.
Ich glaube, wir machen im Discord auch sowas.
Okay, also wir haben jetzt unseren Access Point am Start.
Jetzt gehen wir mal in DHCP Server Leases.
So, wenn wir das Ding geflasht haben und dann diesen Access Point anmelden, dann bekommen wir hier eine IP zugewiesen.
Und dann sehen wir das hier und dann können wir uns hier drauf connecten.
Also, auf geht's würde ich sagen.
Als nächstes müssen wir die Steckdose mit dem Raspberry Pi flashen.
Das heißt, wir verbinden uns jetzt erstmal auf den Raspberry Pi.
Ich hoffe, die IP stimmt.
Scheint zu stimmen.
Ich habe einfach die letzten Raspberry Pi genommen, die ich in der History habe.
Das scheint ja auch zu sein.
Wir machen nochmal ein Update, nur um auf Nummer sicher zu gehen.
So, und jeder, der flashen will, der selbst seine Steckdose flashen will, muss jetzt aufpassen, weil so funktioniert das.
Das ist total einfach.
Man geht auf Github.
Github Tuya Convert.
Lustigerweise ein Projekt von der CT.
Also heise, quasi.
So, man nimmt das Projekt.
Also man nimmt sich diese Url vom Github Projekt.
Geht auf seinen Raspberry Pi.
Installiert sich erstmal eine Runde Shit.
Weil wir brauchen jetzt Shit, um das Repo zu klonen.
Und dann, wenn er fertig ist.
So.
Geht Clone.
Dann klonen wir das in einen Ordner.
Und das war es mehr oder weniger schon.
Der Rest geht mit einem Assistent.
Jithub.
Genau.
Da hat der Niklas echt was angerichtet, dass ich heute noch Shit sage.
Oder Jit zu Git.
So.
Das nächste, was man machen muss.
Man sagt hier Install.
Install Prequisites.
Prerequisites.
Der braucht ein paar Dinger.
Ein MQTT Server, glaube.
Und Dinger.
Keine Ahnung.
Einfach ausführen und machen.
Das ist ein Raspberry Pi 4.
Aber das geht genauso gut mit dem.
Also das hier.
Das ist ein Raspberry Pi 4 mit dem Flir Case.
Aber das geht ganz genauso gut mit dem Raspberry Pi 3.
Ne.
Ich glaube das ist ein.
Ich guck mal gleich, wie viel RAM das Ding hat.
Ich gehe davon aus, dass es ein 4 GB Raspberry Pi.
So.
Jetzt können wir nur hoffen, dass sich die Dinger auch ordentlich flashen lassen.
Flasherino.
Können wir mal kurz gucken.
Ri.
Ja, 4 GB.
4 GB Raspberry Pi.
Ja.
Heute habe ich auf der Arbeit ein Ticket bekommen.
Achtung.
Von unserem Support.
Swap Space.
Auf Server XY voll.
Achtung, Swap Space.
Was, warum?
Was interessiert mich, ob das Server Swappt?
So.
Da habe ich ihn gefragt, der mir das Ticket gegeben hat.
Wie viel RAM ist denn noch frei?
Und da meinte er 20 GB.
Was juckt mich, ob das Ding Swappt?
Wenn er noch.
Also erstens ist natürlich die Frage, warum Swappt der?
Wenn er noch 20 GB frei hat.
Aber die Wege des Linux-Kernels sind unergründlich.
Was das Swapping angeht.
Manchmal.
Aber wenn ein Server 20 GB freies RAM hat, dann ist das richtig.
Ja.
hat da muss man sich keine gedanken machen vor allem kein emergency ticket
hohe hohe wie heißt bei uns hohe priorität an angeben
sauberisch keck weit wir haben nicht die falls wappen ist damit so ein mist
normalerweise gar nicht aufschlägt so gut fertig also sagt next start start
flash so und jetzt muss man darauf achten was dieser assistent einem sagt
please read this carefully das machen wir jetzt nicht
careful yes wir wissen bescheid alles klar keiner übernimmt die garantie dafür
alles gut yes do you wish to terminate ja ja mach yes so access point wieder
aufgemacht so und jetzt kommt gleich ein ganz wichtiger hinweis man muss dass das
funktionalität nicht aufgehoben wird und man muss das funktionalität nicht
aufgehoben werden und man muss das funktionalität nicht aufgehoben werden
funktioniert man muss ein weiteres gerät das hier ist ganz wichtig sonst
funktioniert es nicht das ding macht jetzt ein access point auf der wie trust
heißt damit das mit dem flaschen funktioniert ist man muss ein weiteres
gerät in dieses wlan packen auch wenn das nicht steht es mittlerweile gar
nicht hier connect any other device also muss beispielsweise sein smartphone oder
ein tablet oder sonst was in dieses wie trust wlan hängen das mache ich jetzt
mal hier auf screen mit dem ipad
das kann ich euch nicht zeigen aber ihr geht einfach in irgendeinem x-beliebigen
gerät in die wlan settings und joint einem wlan was wie trust heißt nix no no
got you buzz wie trust flash ihr connected euch daran so und jetzt wird
spannend jetzt kommt die geschichte mit der steckdose put your iot device in auto
config smart config pairing mode led will blink fast okay das macht er automatisch das heißt
das einzige was wir jetzt machen müssen theoretisch ist die steckdose einstecken
klingt vertrauenswürdig das ist auch muss ausbrechen du kannst gucken was es macht
so hier ich versuche das mal ein bisschen ein bisschen hinzuziehen geht nicht so
wirklich gut aber also das einzige was wir jetzt wirklich machen muss ist die
steckdose einstecken und dann gucken dass es im pairing modus blinkt schauen
wir mal versuche ich das mal so zu zeigen pairing modus sollte im pairing modus sein
sollte im pairing modus sein sollte im pairing modus sein sollte im pairing modus sein
Ich hab mein, ähm, das ist gar kein LWL, das ist ein Direct-Attach-Kabel.
Ja, aber hab ich aus Versehen rausgezogen.
Lull.
Wir haben es jetzt nicht gesehen.
Wir haben es nicht gesehen, er hat geflasht.
Aber wir machen das ja noch dreimal, ihr seht's.
Guckt hier.
Er flasht, er flasht das Ding jetzt gerade.
Er flasht das Ding jetzt gerade, ja.
Oder hat er das geflasht?
Mhh.
Ja, funktioniert.
Er flasht, wir haben nix verpasst.
Der flasht jetzt.
Da ist nix pricked.
Da sieht man auch nix bei der Steckdose.
Also ihr müsst euch dann gar nicht wundern, wenn da irgendwie nix blinkt oder so.
Das ist normal, man sieht da nix.
What the fuck?
Okay, also.
Ready to flash third-party-Firmware.
Alles klar.
Wir wollen flash Tasmota machen.
Zwei.
Are you sure Tasmota bin?
Point of no return.
Yes.
Der prickt nicht.
Quatsch, da prickt nix.
Der chat wieder.
Warum seid ihr so scharf drauf, dass ich 30 Euro Sachen kaputt mache?
Wobei, die hatte ja keine 30 Euro, das waren vier Stück für 30 Euro.
Have fun.
Do you want to flash another device?
No.
So.
Jetzt ist das Ding geflasht und was jetzt passiert ist folgendes.
Das kann ich euch jetzt auf dem Tablet zeigen.
Äh, cancel.
So.
Jetzt gibt es den WLAN, der die Steckdose aufmacht.
Jetzt versuche ich euch das mal zu zeigen.
Zack.
Äh.
Moment.
Ich bin dazu.
Zu nubisch für.
Okay.
Alter.
Ist ja richtig pepega, ey.
Über das iPhone.
Über das iPad.
Okay.
Folgendes.
Hier.
Das passiert jetzt.
Erkennt, erkennt man das?
So.
Wenn man, wenn man sich jetzt hier verbindet.
Zu.
Na, das kennt man nicht gescheit.
Moment.
Ich muss es groß machen.
Zack.
Lull.
Ich muss es groß machen.
Ja.
Das kann ja gar nichts.
So.
Jetzt, jetzt.
Jetzt sieht man es eigentlich ganz gut.
Genau.
Also.
So.
Das, das, das bekommt man dann.
Wenn man sich versucht, zu diesem Access guckt.
Ihr seht es hier oben.
Äh.
Das Motor.
Das Ding macht einen Access Point auf.
So.
Und damit man sich da jetzt connecten kann, muss man folgendes machen.
Wir machen jetzt in unserem Small Access Point.
iPad League
OMG
Wir machen jetzt in unserem Small Access Point
Äh
Wollen wir hier irgendwo haben?
What the
Äh
In unserem Small Access Point machen wir jetzt das WLAN an
Und dann connecten wir uns
Zu diesem Access Point
Und ich gehe mal
Hier, dass ihr das gleich seht
Auf Leases
Dass ich per DHCP was bekomme
So
Ich seh grad wie wir das jetzt gescheit machen
Ich muss grad mal aufmachen
Auf dem Tablet
So
Okay, also Fullscreen
Ich darf jetzt nur das Passwort nicht leaken
Lull
Also Fullscreen, man kann jetzt da nicht so viel
Man kann jetzt da nicht so viel verkehrt machen
Man kriegt jetzt dieses Eingabeding hier auf dem Tablet
So
Was man jetzt macht ist, man geht hier drauf
Sagt hey, wir wollen Access Point
Wir wollen dem Access Point joinen
Access Point ist in dem Fall
Home
Und das Passwort sag ich euch jetzt nicht
Weil Monka, Monka Leak
So, und wenn man sich da jetzt vertippt
Ist ziemlich dumm
Weil, dann muss man das Ding resetten
Und es sackt
Oh, ich glaub ich hab mich vertippt
Lull
Moment, sag ich doch
Okay, alles klar
Passt
Okay, dann machen wir das hier
Domainplan, oder?
Danach sagt ihr Save
Und das war's
Dann steht da, es reconnected
Und wenn das reconnected
Dann sollte es jetzt zum Access Point reconnecten
Oh, guck mal da
Was haben wir denn da? Eine Lease?
Was könnte das wohl nur sein?
Was hier eine dynamische IP bekommen hat
Das klingt ja ganz
Nach unserem Tasmota
Oder auch nicht?
Achso, ich hab ja gar keine Route dahin
Moment
Wie komm ich denn da jetzt ran?
Da hab ich mir mit dem Small Access Point noch gar keine Gedanken gemacht
Äh, wie komm ich denn da jetzt hin?
Was hat ein Access Point für eine IP?
Also muss ich jetzt sagen, Moment, Moment
Route at
192.168.8
.0
Slash 24
Äh
Was da?
Geht das überhaupt mit Slash 24?
Was?
Aus dem Kopf jetzt nicht gebacken
Nope
Route at
Muss ich GW davor machen?
Ne
Oh ne
Oder war das
355?
Muss man das so machen?
Ne
Oh fuck
Ich weiß es aus dem Kopf nicht mehr
Ah, scheint zu gehen
So
Ping
192.168.88.154
Nope
Okay, das ist jetzt so
Das ist dumm, wie komm ich jetzt an die Kiste dran?
Das müsste doch jetzt eigentlich funktionieren
Dass es ein Firewall Problem ist?
Das sollte eigentlich kein Firewall Problem sein, weil ich alles erlaubt hab von
Moment, nein, ich hab nicht alles erlaubt von lokal
Das ist bestimmt ein Firewall Problem
Also Add
Wir wollen Source, Source Address
Slash 24
Äh
In Interface, Dings out Interface
Wireless
Wollen wir alles erlauben?
Ich hoffe nicht.
Ich hoffe das stimmt, was ich hier treibe
Fuck
Ja gut
Moment
Geht das überhaupt richtig?
Traceroute
Das geht falsch
Ich hab nicht
Ich hab nicht richtig
Ich hab keine richtige Route gesetzt
Ach du Scheiße, wie geht denn das?
Äh
Meine Güte, das weiß ich doch jetzt aus dem Kopf nicht
Wie setz ich ne Route für das Netz?
Mensch
Chat, ihr wisst das doch
Ihr wisst das doch bestimmt aus dem Kopf, oder?
Ähm
Fire?
Ah, guck mal hier
So, hier
IP, Route, Add
Ja, jetzt Big Brain
Time
Hoho
Und jetzt?
Trace
Das sieht besser aus
Ding
Das geht immer noch nicht
But why?
Das ist richtig
Aber der Weg zurück fehlt
Das stimmt
Der Weg
Ne
Ne, der Weg zurück
Der Weg zurück
fehlt
Eigentlich nicht
Das ist direkt angeschlossen
Das ist nicht der Raspberry
Äh, da muss ich jetzt mal kurz überlegen
Ne, ne, ICMP ist nicht deaktiviert
Wie krieg ich denn das alte wieder weg?
Ja, das hätte ich vielleicht vorher mal ausprobieren sollen
Geht das irgendwie Dell?
Ne
Dell?
Ja
Ok, die Firewall nicht die Steckdose
Wir können mal gucken, ob es prinzipiell funktioniert
Wir machen einfach mal einen Ping da drüber
Also
Server IP von dem Ding ist folgendes hier
192.168, das da
Es kann wirklich sein, dass es der Rückweg ist
So, wir machen jetzt mal einen Ping
Von der Kiste aus
Dazu gehen wir mal hier Terminal
Ich glaube, das ist einfacher
Man kann auch Ping über das Webinterface machen, aber...
Ping
Pong
192.168
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man den Ping vom Mikro-Ticker auf der Kommandozeile bedient
Timeout?
Wait a minute
Warum?
Der Router selbst sollte aber nicht timeouten
Keck, wait
Der Router selbst sollte definitiv nicht timeouten
Kaputt, ne
Das ist irgendwie eine Firewall-Geschichte
Geht da aber das richtige Interface raus?
Naja, es sind zwei Sachen angeschlossen
Es muss schon...
Traceroute?
Ne, keine Ahnung, wie das hier funktioniert
Mikro-Tick-Kommandozeile kann ich nicht wirklich gut
Hm...
Last Scene
Hat sich das Ding ausgeschaltet?
Zack
Oh, Make Static
Da kriegt es immer die gleiche IP
Ich starte das mal neu
Ich starte das Ding mal neu
Ziehen wir mal Steckdose raus
Das kann man jetzt ja gefahrlos machen
Kein Problem
Stecken wir die Steckdose wieder rein
Expires after, okay
Jetzt hat sich das definitiv was geholt
MonkaS
Warum?
Warum kann der Router
Selbst
Das Ding nicht pingen?
Habe ich irgendwelche Firewall-Geschichten
MonkaS-ig eingerichtet?
Oder was ist hier los?
Also zumindest der Router selbst sollte das doch pingen können
Warum geht das nicht?
Also ich gehe davon aus, das Ding ist ab
Gar keine Frage
So, es wird irgendeine Firewall
Irgendeine Firewall-Geschichte sein
Also, wir haben Forward ist alles erlaubt
Forward ist alles erlaubt
Die Antwort von der Steckdose muss inbound in den Router erlaubt sein
Stimmt
Wenn ich den Router pinge, muss das erlaubt sein?
Wobei ich habe
Ah ne, das liegt hier dran glaube ich
Das muss ich weiter runter machen
Wartet mal
Ich habe, ich habe mich glaube ich selbst gebetet
Ich glaube ich selbst gebetet
Weil ich habe established related
Das müsste aber eigentlich doch funktionieren
Das ist, das ist die Antwort da drauf
Das müsste eigentlich klappen
Aha
Ich habe mich selbst gebetet
Mit meiner bescheuerten Regel hier
Jetzt kann der Router zwar selbst nicht pingen
Aber ich komme drauf
Ja gut, ob der Router selbst pingen kann oder nicht
Ist mir vollkommen egal
Aber ich komme drauf
Alles klar
So
Ich habe, ich habe mich selbst gebetet
Mit meiner komischen
Regel hier
Die ich aber eigentlich gar nicht bräuchte oder?
Bräuchte ich gar nicht
Weil ich droppe doch eh alles was nicht erlaubt ist
Okay
Ich glaube, ich glaube ich habe es
Ich glaube ich habe es gecheckt
Warum das nicht funktioniert
Der Ping kommt an
Aber der Ping kommt nicht zurück
Das heißt ich muss das da oben drüber schieben
Und jetzt
Geht's
Das ist das, das ist die Antwort erlauben
Alles klar
Okay
Wunderbar
IP am Start
Zack, können wir uns drauf verbinden
Und wir haben unser Tasmota am Start
Wir können jetzt die Steckdose an- und ausschalten
Lass mich mal kurz hören, ob es funktioniert
Nein, es funktioniert nichts
Wir gucken uns
Ich, ich blende es euch
Ich blende es euch hier oben mal ein
In der Hoffnung, dass ich das hinkriege
Ohne, dass ich das Kabel irgendwie wieder rausreiße
So, dass ihr das seht
Zack
Müssen wir das so machen
Sieht jetzt zwar nicht schön aus
Aber zweckmäßig
Also wenn alles funktioniert
Wenn alles funktioniert
Kann ich über das Webinterface das Ding an- und ausschalten
Und dann geht hier auch die Steckdose an- und aus
Templates setzen, genau
Dann geht auch die Steckdose an- und aus
Aktuell passiert gar nichts
Aber wenn ich hier drauf drücke
Passiert auch nichts
Weil er keine Ahnung hat
Wie das interne Relay mit diesem Schalter zu funktionieren ist
Mit diesem Schalter zusammenhängt
Deswegen muss ich mir tatsächlich
Genau was der Chat gesagt hat
Ein Template dafür raussuchen
Das macht man folgendermaßen
Wir können by the way auch gleich mal Tasmota upgraden
Dazu gehen wir mal GitHub Tasmota
Das ist da wo die Firmware herkommt
Gehen wir mal ins offizielle GitHub Repo
Und
Was passiert eigentlich wenn die Dinger custom geflasht abfackeln?
Nichts
Du hast ja Hardware mäßig nichts geändert
Warum sollten die abfackeln durch Custom Firmware?
So, der Michael
Wo ist der Michael?
Tasmota
Nein, Tasmota, Tasmota
Du hast doch hier Tasmota
Ich hab Dich mal in der Gelegenheit
Das ist ja Tasmota
Das ist aber da
Ist ja Tasmota
Das ist ja Tasmota
Wahnsinn
Das ist ja der Tasmota
Das ist das gleiche
Tasmota
Das ist der alte Tasmota
Das ist der Tasmota
Aber wie ist das denn?
Wie ist das hier?
Alter
Guck mal
Was ist hier?
Was ist das hier?
Was ist das da?
Aber warte mal
Ich finde das hier auch
Ich finde es ganz cool
Das ist ja ofenbar
Wir machen vor
Hoffentlich ist genug Platz drauf, dass ich updaten kann.
Wenn nicht, kann ich euch gleich mal auch zeigen, wie man richtig Tasmota updatet.
Es gibt da nämlich so ein paar Stolpersteine, in die man fallen könnte.
Ich schiebe das mal hier vor, dass ich das wieder finde.
Also wenn man Tasmota upgraden will, einfach den OTA-Link einfügen.
Das würde ich tatsächlich mal, ich würde es selbst updaten, weil in meinem normalen IoT-WLAN kommen die Kisten auch nicht ins Internet.
So, Firmware upgrade.
Upgrade Tasmota BIN GZ.
So, jetzt kann es zu einem Problem führen, dass das Gerät nicht genug Speicher hat zum upgraden.
Das sagt er einem aber dann.
So, upgrade, start upgrade.
So, der uploadet jetzt.
Und wenn er zu wenig Speicher hat, wird er meckern.
Es kann durchaus sein, dass die Dinger zu wenig Speicher haben.
Wenn die zu wenig Speicher haben, dann muss man einen Trick machen, dass das...
Okay, es hat funktioniert.
Wenn die nämlich zu wenig Speicher haben, dann muss man erst eine Minimal-Firmware flashen und danach die richtige Firmware flashen.
So, jetzt haben wir das Ding geupgradet.
Hier machen wir mal unseren Access Point hier auf.
Den schiebe ich auch ein bisschen vor.
Access Point.
Wo ist DHCP?
DHCP-Server, Leases, alles klar.
Nichts getan, ist auch wieder neu gestartet.
Man bekommt relativ einfach mit, ob IoT-Geräte neu gestartet sind, wenn die Least Time sich resettet für die DHCP-Adresse.
Weil ansonsten sieht man es nicht und manchmal sind die Geräte ja auch im Keller.
So, da sind wir.
Neueste Tasmota-Version.
Poggers.
Easy Update, Easy Live.
So, und jetzt kommt das Wichtigste, was man machen muss, damit Tasmota-Geräte funktionieren.
Man muss Tasmota-Geräten ein Template setzen.
Template ist ein...
Das ist falsch.
Warte mal.
Äh, hierhin?
Genau.
Also man kann das Template entweder von Hand konfigurieren, welche Pins wohin gemappt sind.
Das ist für den Arsch.
Man muss hier rein.
Und dann geht man ins Internet und sucht sich in einer Tasmota-Datenbank raus, was man denn für ein Gerät hat und was man für ein Template braucht.
Da gibt es beispielsweise die hier.
Und da suchen wir jetzt mal unsere Steckdose raus.
Ähm.
Ah, nee, nicht.
Search.
Gosund.
SP irgendwas heißen die Dinger.
SP.
So, wenn wir Glück haben.
Das könnten die sein.
SP 112.
Es gibt aber auch die.
Also wir haben jetzt zur Auswahl zwei verschiedene Versionen.
Das wird da so ein bisschen, so ein bisschen Painschamp.
Die muss man jetzt einfach ausprobieren.
Was man auch noch braucht.
Was man auch noch gucken kann.
Ist aber das das bringt meistens nix.
Man kann irgendwo gucken, hat sich im Chat gerade einer geschrieben, genau Configure, Configure Module.
Wo ist, wo ist das?
Ja, ob das hier schon drinsteht, aber in der Regel steht das hier nicht drinne.
Nee, guck, da steht irgendwie Gosund SP1.
Also in der Regel sind, sind die Templates für die Geräte nicht, nicht mit dabei.
So, deswegen geht man jetzt hier auf Configuration.
Configurate Other sucht sich hier das passende Template raus.
Jetzt ist die Frage, was wir nehmen.
Gosund V34 oder Gosund.
Tja, wir haben zur Auswahl die Version V34 und die Version Dings.
Also was ist denn der Unterschied dazwischen?
It is possible that your device will enter a boot loop.
Oh, das ist schlecht.
Das ist, das ist schlecht.
Boot loop.
Doch es kann was passieren.
Boot loop ist schlecht.
This device now comes with a Wi-Fi module.
Incompatible, oh.
Ja, die neuen.
Old version.
Ah, die neue Version geht mit Tasmota gar nicht.
Also die wollten uns, die wollten uns eigentlich nur darauf hinweisen, dass die neue Version nicht funktioniert.
Sehe ich das richtig?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Ich, ich probiere das jetzt einfach aus.
Wir, wir, wir testen, wir testen das jetzt einfach.
Mehr als kaputt machen können wir es nicht.
Aber in der Regel kann da eigentlich nichts kaputt gehen, außer dass es nicht funktioniert.
Schau mal auf Manufakturer.
Ja, so wirklich.
Ich habe auch die, ich habe auch die Packung nicht mehr.
Keine Ahnung.
Schau bei den GPIOs.
Die eine hat zwei Relays.
Ach ja, haben noch beide zwei Relays.
Sie müssen zwei Relays haben.
Einmal dafür und einmal für die USB.
Ich nehme einfach das hier jetzt fertig.
Easy.
Gucken jetzt, was funktioniert.
Zack.
Configure Template.
Activate.
Häkchen setzen.
Save.
Easy Prick.
Da prickt sich nichts.
Force Champ.
So, gucken, ob er rebooted.
Er ist wieder da.
Zack.
Da sind wir.
Seht ihr es?
Moment.
Da.
Aus.
An.
Erkennt man, dass es blau.
Aus.
An.
Funktioniert.
Ich kann euch auch zeigen, ich kann euch auch zeigen.
Der einen...
Der andere toggelt друз Voilà.
Ich zeige euch auch jetzt, dass es funktioniert.
Wo ist die POGgaslampe?
Hier, POGgaslamp.
Wo ist es?
Netzteil.
Stecker.
Alter.
Geht nicht so einfach rein.
Stecker.
Lampe.
Lampen, auf.
Lampe ist noch raus.
Und jetzt, passt auf, an, bam, Kunst.
Da haben wir aus, aus.
Also ihr seht, das läuft.
Ja, das müssen wir gleich noch kalibrieren.
Die Anzeige ist Keckweight.
290 Volt, Alter.
China-Chinesen-Kram.
Kannste, kannste, knicke.
Das müssen wir gleich noch kalibrieren.
Haben die auch eine API?
Das machen wir jetzt, das machen wir jetzt alles.
Ich muss mir das mal aufschreiben, dass ich es nicht vergesse.
Wir machen jetzt MQTT.
Wir machen, äh, Calibration und Home Assistant-Integration.
Haben wir alles.
Ja, du kannst das über das Web-Interface toggeln, du kannst es über eine Web-API toggeln oder du kannst es über MQTT toggeln.
Das ist viel besser.
Also das Motor kann fast, fast alles ansteuern.
So, und für was der zweite Schalter ist, kann ich euch auch zeigen.
Der zweite Schalter ist für USB.
Ähm, die Sache ist nur die, ich habe jetzt hier nichts da, was ich per USB...
Wollen wir kurz gucken, was ich per USB anschließen kann.
Also der zweite Schalter ist hierfür, guckt, der hat...
Ich mach das mal wieder weg, das steht sonst wirklich nur im Weg rum.
Guckt, das Ding hat unten USB.
Der zweite, der zweite ist, äh, der zweite Schalter ist für USB.
Ich überleg grad, was mach ich denn da jetzt mal?
Den Raspberry Pi nicht, den brauche ich noch.
Ach, ich hab eine Idee, was ich dran mach.
Ich hab doch hier bestimmt, ich hab hier doch irgendwo noch eine alte, eine alte Maus.
Hier, guck mal.
Näh, ist so dreckig.
Ich hab hier kein gescheites USB-Gerät, wo ich euch das jetzt mal zeigen könnte.
Über den Access-Point selbst, Access-Point selbst an- und ausschalten wäre ziemlich dumm, da krieg ich den mal an.
Handy-Ladekabel.
Hm.
Ja, ja, aber das Handy nimmt gerade auf, ich hab ja kein Gerät.
Was nehm ich denn mal?
Ein paar USBs.
Ich muss doch irgendein, irgendein USB-Gerät hier haben.
Warte mal, das kann doch nicht sein.
Irgendwas, was ich dafür verwende.
Was haben wir denn hier?
Webcam.
Lag noch neben am Sofa.
Olle verstaubte Tastatur.
Aber ich glaub, die hat RGB.
Ja, Olle verstaubte Tastatur.
Aber die können wir mal anschließen.
Und wenn das funktioniert, wenn ich jetzt den richtigen Stecker finde, hier den da,
dann sollte es eigentlich angehen per RGB.
Ups.
Es sei denn, die muss ich erst synken.
Toggle 2.
Ah.
Nope.
Die Tastatur geht wohl erst an, wenn sie USB erkennt.
Okay, das ist Painschamp.
Ihr müsst mir einfach glauben, dass du da mit USB schaltest.
Gibt doch nicht, vor jedem USB.
Powerbank.
Powerbank ist ne gute Idee.
Wartet mal.
Ich hab das optimale Gerät gefunden, um euch zu zeigen, dass USB funktioniert.
Optimales Gerät.
Ich hab doch so ein USB-Strommesser.
Guck, USB. Funktioniert.
So.
Alter, was willst du immer, Windows?
So, wenn ich das jetzt ausschalte, ist aus.
Wenn ich's anschalte, geht's an.
Also ich glaub, besser demonstrieren kann man's nicht.
Auch mit 5 Volt, wie das sein sollte.
So, und das heißt, hiermit toggle ich die Steckdose, mit dem anderen kann ich USB ausschalten.
Machen wir mal beides aus.
Jetzt ist USB auch aus.
Genau.
So, Sekunde.
Jetzt muss ich mal kurz wieder das Kabel hin.
So, so funktioniert das.
Ich glaube, jetzt hat man's gesehen.
So, und jetzt kommen wir mal dazu, was man Cooles mit Tasmotor noch machen kann.
Was wir jetzt machen werden ist, weil gab's ja grad die Frage, ob man das über API steuern kann.
Tasmotor kann's über alles mögliche steuern.
Wisst ihr auch den USB-Stromverbrauch?
Ja, dafür ist es gedacht.
Also das kann ihr sagen, wieviel Volt auf dem USB-Anschluss sind, wieviel Amperegrad drüber gehen und im Endeffekt kannst ihr da noch ungefähr ausrechnen, was das verbraucht.
So, also jetzt haben wir die Steckdose und jetzt kommt das Beste, das Ganze müssen wir jetzt in unsere Home Automation integraten.
Das ist unsere Test Home Assistant Installation.
Und es ist mittlerweile relativ simpel.
Home Assistant und Tasmotor miteinander zu verbinden.
Ich zeige euch das Ganze mal, wie easy das mittlerweile ist.
Was wir machen müssen ist erstmal, ja das 290, kalibrieren müssen wir ja auch noch, hab ich ganz vergessen, jaja.
Kalibrieren machen wir dann.
Wir verbinden das jetzt erstmal mit Home Assistant, dass wir das schön verwenden können.
So, da muss man in Configuration gehen.
Configuration.
Configuration und dann zu MQTT.
Da gibt man jetzt ein.
Die IP vom Home Assistant.
Port 1338.
Das ist ja das, was wir eben gerade hier auch in der Firewall freigeschaltet haben, dass es funktioniert.
Ja, also Forward zu 213, Port 1883.
Weil wir das hier brauchen.
Also, Tasmotor soll sich verbinden dahin.
So, User, ich hab keine Ahnung, was haben wir denn für einen User für MQTT vergeben?
Äh, Configure.
Ne, warte mal, wo ist das nochmal?
Configuration.
Ach, der Default User haben wir, ne?
Der Default User ist glaube ich Admin 123456.
Können wir mal gucken.
Wir gucken jetzt einfach, ob sich das verbinden kann.
Also, MQTT-Verbindung, Passwort 123456.
Äh, User, Admin, glaube.
Ich würde normalerweise dafür, und habe ich auch bei meinen Geräten gemacht, ich würde einen extra User anlegen, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich würde einen extra User anlegen, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber gucken wir mal, ob der sich verbinden kann.
Don't save.
New Connection.
Bam.
Jawoll, funktioniert.
Also.
Unser Tasmotor kann zumindest schon mit unserem MQTT reden.
Und jetzt ist eigentlich die Sache schon fast geritzt.
Jetzt geht man in die Configuration, Integration, sagt Add New Integration.
Tasmotor, das ist mittlerweile ziemlich easy im Vergleich zu früher.
Ja.
Man kann MQTT natürlich auch über HTTPS, äh, nicht über HTTPS.
Also, äh, verschlüsselt machen.
Aber meistens ist es tatsächlich der ganz normale Unverschlüssel, ja.
So, Tasmotor.
Äh, we discover this.
Want to set up.
Äh.
Okay, das kenne ich noch nicht.
Yes.
Äh, submit.
Guck mal.
Und schon hat er sie erkannt.
Gosund.
112V3, Tasmotor.
Finished.
So.
Und jetzt habe ich 21 Entities von meiner Steckdose hier drinne.
Unter anderem habe ich jetzt hier meine Heimautomatisierung drinne.
Kann man das hier vielleicht ein bissl.
Na doof.
Also ich hab, äh.
Da ist es.
Warte mal.
Weiß.
Ne, das meintest du Heizchamp.
Das ist falsch.
Den Heizchamp wollen wir heute nicht.
Hier.
Ja, wir haben Energieverbrauch.
Äh.
Datum solch.
Man kann das an- und ausschalten.
Und sowas in der Richtung.
Disabled Entities.
So.
Jetzt sollten wir das erstmal ausprobieren.
Äh.
So.
Jetzt sollten wir das erstmal ordentlich benennen.
Weil.
Die haben Autodiscovery drinne.
Mittlerweile ist, äh.
Ist HomeAssist und MQT die Autodiscovery Standardmäßig dabei.
So.
Wir sollten die Dinge jetzt erstmal ordentlich benennen.
Dass wir wissen was was ist.
So.
Weil später hast du 5 Steckdosen und alle heißen Tasmota.
Deswegen sagen wir jetzt mal Name.
Das da ist.
Ähm.
Gehen wir mal.
Machen wir mal ein Beispiel.
Keiner.
Das würden wir jetzt verwenden für.
Wohnzimmer.
Ist was Schwachsinn.
Ähm.
TV.
So.
Wohnzimmer.
TV.
USB.
Also.
Ich.
Ich würde die ja irgendwie sinnvoll verwenden.
Äh.
Benutzen.
Dass ich die später wieder finde.
Ja.
Ich weiß.
Man kann seine Steckdose vergeben.
Aber ich mag das.
Mag das hier.
Hier.
Ja.
So.
Jetzt können wir mal gucken.
Ob das richtig gemappt ist.
Ich mach mal USB an.
Und USB geht an.
Ich mach USB aus.
Und USB geht aus.
Ist richtig gemappt.
Ihr.
Ihr sehts ja hier.
Guckt.
Ich mach mal USB an.
Und USB geht aus.
Funktioniert.
Richtig gemappt.
Stromverbrauch ist noch ziemlich pepega.
Funktioniert auch nicht.
Aber.
Nachdem wir das ganze jetzt in unserem Home Assistant drin haben.
Können wir jetzt einfach sagen.
Ich schieb das mal kurz hier unten hin.
Wollen wir jetzt einfach sagen.
Okay.
Ähm.
Ich will das.
Ich will das mal in mein Dashboard integrieren.
So.
Hier haben wir die Heizung.
Da ist es vielleicht nicht so sinnvoll.
Das heißt.
Wir machen jetzt mal ein neues Tab.
Und zwar ein neues Tab fürs Wohnzimmer.
Icon.
MDI.
Was ist ein schönes Icon für Wohnzimmer?
Icon.
MDI.
Was ist ein schönes Icon für Wohnzimmer?
TV.
Vielleicht.
Weiß ich nicht.
Ob das äh.
Gültig ist.
Save.
Hopp.
Äh.
Icon.
MDI Icons.
Couch.
Couch ist gut.
Wir gucken mal was es für Icons gibt.
Couch.
Alter.
Diese Seite ist so krass langsam.
Couch.
Ja.
Hier.
Das ist.
Das ist doch gut für Wohnzimmer!
Sofa.
Sofa heißt es.
Das ist doch gut.
Sofa!
Da ist es!
Zack!
Ist unser Sofa.
So!
Also wir haben jetzt.
Wir haben jetzt Tabs.
Für alles was wir brauchen.
Wir haben unseren Keller.
Den machen wir mal weg.
So wir haben jetzt haben叫 Home Tab.
Das benennen wir auch mal um.
Finde ich Doof.
Das heißt äh.
MDI.
Home.
So.
Jetzt haben wir Tabs.
Michael in fünf Spieljahren du bist auch am Start.
Endlich!
Wir haben gerade Tasmota geflasht und weißt du, habe ich gleich an dich gedacht, weißt du, wie die aktuelle Tasmota-Version heißt?
Guck mal.
Ich habe gedacht, wo ist er denn?
So.
So, jetzt haben wir unser Dashboard eingestellt, dass ihr das testet.
Also wir haben Dashboard für Home, Dashboard fürs Wohnzimmer, Dashboard für den Keller mit der Heizung drin.
Hast du das neue Video vom Auer gesehen?
Ja.
Teilweise zumindest, teilweise.
Können wir uns am Sonntag komplett angucken, da kann ich ein bisschen Sellout für meinen Hetzner Cloud Code machen.
So, und hier binden wir jetzt die Steckdose ein.
Also, so, wir brauchen ein Button, Wohnzimmer TV, das schlägt da sogar schon vor.
Nicht, weil das Wohnzimmer ist, sondern weil das das einzige ist, was wir wahrscheinlich haben.
Show State können wir noch dran machen, On, Off, Show Icon, Icon ist sinnvoll.
Show Name, ja, ist vielleicht nicht verkehrt.
So, und jetzt haben wir einen Knopf, wo wir unsere Steckdose ausmachen können in unserem Dashboard.
Das Dashboard lässt sich bedienen.
Tablet.
Smartphone, Desktop, überall.
Integration, total einfach.
Was ich jetzt noch empfehlen würde, ist folgendes.
Weil man wahrscheinlich im Wohnzimmer ein bisschen mehr als eine Steckdose hat, würde ich das anders machen.
Und das ist auch ein bisschen fett.
Ich würde hier eine, ein Grid noch machen.
Ein Grid mit drei Columns und da würde ich das reinstecken.
Das ist, das ist sinnvoller.
Ja, dann machen wir Wohnzimmer USB und Wohnzimmer.
Jetzt ist übrigens auch wichtig.
Dass die halt richtig benannt sind, sonst würde man die hier nicht mehr gescheit finden.
Wohnzimmer.
So, der Name ist ein bisschen groß, also überschreiben wir den Namen mal und sagen,
äh, einfach mal Show Name, einmal ausnehmen und sagen wir, äh, EV-USB.
Oh, ne, umgedreht.
Äh, hier, EV und das hier ist V-USB.
So.
Und die schmeißen wir weg.
Und schon haben wir in unserem Wohnzimmer zwei Knöpfe, wo wir Geräte mit an- und ausschalten können.
Wir können unseren Fernseher an- und ausschalten, das schaltet jetzt hier an- und aus, die Steckdose, oder wir können USB-Geräte an- und ausschalten.
Das schaltet, wie man sieht, hier an- und aus.
Guckt, an, aus, an, geht.
So, und da muss man echt sagen, die Integration ist ziemlich easy gewesen, oder?
Das jetzt in Home Assistant zu integrieren.
Okay.
Um nicht, um nicht zu sagen...
Oh, der, was im Netto-Zentrallager, das Serverraum ist voll mit RGB, warum habt ihr RGB im Serverraum?
Also, das bunte LEDs vorne an den Servern sind ja aber RGB.
Ja, Chainlord, deswegen musst du ihnen das ja auch machen.
So, jetzt können wir hier unseren Fernseher an- und ausschalten.
Und ihr seht auch, die Latency ist durchaus in Ordnung hier, guckt.
Aus, an, aus, an.
Also, die Latency ist, ist, ist vollkommen okay.
So.
Und in Wirklichkeit hätte man jetzt natürlich noch mehr Einträge.
Ja, man könnte hier beispielsweise sein Android-TV als Player reinmachen, oder was auch immer noch alles.
In dem Fall haben wir jetzt halt nur zwei Steckdosen drinne.
So, und jetzt, jetzt wollen wir ja kalibrieren, hatten wir noch gesagt, weil das Ganze ein wenig unrealistisch ist.
290 Volt.
Das stimmt was nicht.
Das blöde ist, warum ich das jetzt nur, ja sagen wir mal, sehr behelfsmäßig kalibrieren kann ist,
ich hab nix da, wovon ich weiß, was das braucht.
Ich kann, ich kann jetzt, ich kann jetzt das hier anpassen, dass das nicht stimmt.
Ich kann das jetzt, ich kann das jetzt anpassen auf 230 Volt und gucken, also, dass er das anders rechnet.
Aber ich hab keine Glühbirne da und ich hab auch keine gescheite Fassung da, um das anzuschließen.
Ich hab's letztes Mal mitgebracht.
Ich hab's letztes Mal mit meinem Heizlüfter gemacht.
Da geht das auch, ging das auch ganz gut.
Aber ich hab jetzt nix gescheites da.
Du machst es immer mit einem 5 Watt Netzteil vom Handy.
Ja gut, aber dann weißt du ja nicht, was, ob das wirklich 5...
Raubsauger.
Ne, ich hab da glaube ich nix gescheites.
Aber wir können zumindest mal, wir können zumindest mal gucken, wie man das kalibrieren würde.
Weil das ist, das ist in Tasmota ein bisschen, sagen wir mal, ein bisschen um die Ecke.
Tasmota Calibration.
So, Gosund.
Da steht das wahrscheinlich auch irgendwo drin, oder?
Gosund.
Power Monitoring Calibration.
Genau, also, was müssen wir machen?
Great Multimeter, Alter.
Gut, ich hab'n, ich hab'n schieler Chinesen Multimeter.
So.
Power Set, Verify Power Reading.
Ja, das stimmt nicht.
Voltage Set will ich machen.
Voltage Set.
Da können wir jetzt zum Beispiel sagen, hey.
Da gehen wir in die Konsole.
Sagen Voltage Set 230.
Und wenn wir Glück haben, sieht das jetzt schon ein bisschen besser aus.
So, und jetzt könnten wir testen, ob der Verbrauch halbwegs stimmt.
Ich hab' aber nix, um's damit zu testen.
Moin, it's FIFA Pro.
Ich hab' leider nix gescheites, um das zu testen.
Also, ich muss mal gucken, ob ich das iPad zum Beispiel mal laden kann oder so.
Wir probieren das mal aus.
Wir laden mal das, wir laden mal das iPad.
Guck mal, da hab' ich doch was da.
Wir können sogar halbwegs genau gucken, ob das, ob das, ob das, nee, können wir nicht.
Komm mal hier rein.
iPad.
iPad dran.
So.
Und nun, achso, es ist eingeschaltet.
Okay.
Wir verbrauchen angeblich 17 Watt.
Das erscheint mir ein bisschen viel, oder?
Ich kann das nicht in den USB-Messer stecken, weil das so'n dummer, so'n, so'n dummers, äh, hier, Ding ist.
USB-C.
Und ich glaub', der hat kein USB-C.
Hat der USB-C?
Ah, der hat USB-C.
Easy.
Da können wir tatsächlich gucken, ob das stimmt.
Wir können doch gucken, ob das stimmt.
Also, der meint, äh, der meint gar nix.
Ah, das ist Input.
Das ist, das ist ja dumm, das ist nur Input.
Das bringt mir ja gar nix.
Es gibt nur den als Output.
Na, Painschamp, alter.
Da brauch' ich, ich brauch', ich brauch' nen Light, ich brauch' nen, nen Lightning-Kabel.
Hab' ich nicht noch nen Lightning-Kabel?
Hab' ich nicht noch nen Lightning-Kabel mit normalen USB dran?
Muss ich doch hier irgendwo haben, Mann.
Was ist'n das hier zum Beispiel?
Hahaha.
Leute, ich hab' nen Lightning-Kabel gefunden.
Aber guckt mal.
Richtiger Anschluss, alles klar.
Aber jetzt, Achtung, Achtung.
Es war mal ein Lightning-Kabel.
Ich hab' wahrscheinlich, ähm, Kabel gebraucht.
Ähm, okay.
Ich hab' doch bestimmt noch mehr.
Lightning-Kabel los.
Lightning.
Ich hab' doch bestimmt irgendwo noch nen Lightning-Kabel.
Ich glaub', ich hab' im Schlafzimmer noch eins.
Zack, ich geh' mal schnell ins Schlafzimmer.
Ich glaub', ich hab' im Schlafzimmer eins.
Zum Aufladen.
Oder hab' ich hier vielleicht am Schreibtisch noch eins?
Ich bin gleich wieder da.
Okay.
Leute, ich hab's geschafft.
Ich hab's geschafft.
Ich hab' ein Lightning-Kabel.
Das können wir ausprobieren.
Zack.
Ich bait it.
So.
Wir haben 5 Volt, 1,4 Ampere, also 7 Watt ungefähr.
Wenn das stimmt.
Erkennt man das überhaupt bei euch gescheit?
Also halbwegs, oder?
So wirklich gut nicht.
7 Watt haben wir angeblich.
Meine Steckdose.
Ah, fuck. Guck mal, der misst USB nicht.
RIP, alter. RIP.
Jetzt bräuchte ich
mit dem USB
nen 230 Volt auf USB
um das dann da einzustecken.
Oh, so was hab' ich jetzt nicht mehr da.
Ich mein', ich könnte
die Steckdose da oben reinstecken.
Steckdose in Steckdose.
Aber so ne...
Hab' ich bestimmt, Leute.
Ich brauch' ein USB-Netzteil.
Hab' ich doch bestimmt irgendwo hier.
Das Problem ist, ich hab' hier so viel Zeug rumliegen.
Ich hab' garantiert nen USB-Netzteil.
Steckdosen.
Ich weiß, wo ich nen USB-Netzteil hab'.
AliExpress regelt.
Guck mal hier.
Bester Hersteller.
Shit-Tag.
Scheiß.
Das ist irgendwie ein 20er-Pack.
Die hab' ich mal gekauft, auch in China.
Shit-Tag.
Der Name allein schon, Mann.
Sagt alles.
Okay, machen wir das raus.
Shit-Tag rein. Zack.
Gut.
Ah, nee. Zack. Stimmt nicht.
Lull.
Was ein Teil.
Was ein Turm, Alter.
Was ein Turm.
Ah, jetzt sind wir bei 10 Watt.
Erkenn' den, glaub' ich, jetzt auch ganz gut.
Okay, 10 Watt. Was haben wir hier?
14.
Also, es ist ein bisschen off, würd' ich sagen, ne?
So. Er ist da mal 0,077.
Und in Wirklichkeit sind es
zwei Amp... Hä?
Ja, gut, das ist Spannungswandlung und so.
Das kann man jetzt... Das kann man hier nicht wirklich zählen.
Das geht ja...
Das geht ja quasi 230 Volt
auf 5 Volt.
Das passt nicht.
Also, das hier...
Na, das kann schon sein, dass es
ein bisschen mehr braucht.
Ich mein', das ist ja nun wirklich nichts
wirklich, soll ich, aussagekräftiges
hier, was ich da gerade sehe.
Ja, wir können's vielleicht ein bisschen anpassen.
Noch ein bisschen runter.
Also, wir können, wie gesagt,
äh...
Power
Calibration...
Power Set.
Okay, Power Reading in the Web
von Fritz Behrmann.
Okay, Power Set, sagen wir mal...
Power Set...
12. So.
Okay.
Das kommt jetzt ungefähr hin.
Easy.
So, wir könnten das jetzt...
jetzt einfach testen.
Ich könnte ins Bad und meinen Heizlüfter anschließen.
Soll ich machen?
Der müsste ungefähr 1000 Watt brauchen, wenn er an ist.
Ah.
Scheiß drauf, oder? Ja, mach.
Wollen wir was ausprobieren?
Ich... Ich mach den Heizlüfter.
So.
Ich hoffe, dieser Billig-Access-Point
reicht bis ins Bad.
Ich hab' jetzt wieder angeschlossen.
Haha, funktioniert.
Funktioniert? Okay.
On.
Also ich mein', hey, es ist fucking ungenau,
aber sooo ungenau ist es jetzt auch nicht.
Es kommt schon
ungefähr hin.
Das kommt schon umge... ungefähr hin.
Oh. RIP.
So. Äh, was hab' ich...
Was hab' ich jetzt verkehrt gemacht?
Was hab' ich jetzt... Das macht man wahrscheinlich nicht so, oder?
Nein, nein, ich hab' keine Lampe.
Ich hab' keine Lampe, dass wir das ordentlich machen könnten.
Gut. Scheiß drauf.
Dann sieht man mal wieder, man muss das
richtig machen, aber ich kann's grad' nicht ordentlich machen.
Ich hab' die passende Hardware dafür nicht.
Ich hab' nen Multimeter, aber ich renn'
jetzt da bestimmt nicht ins Bad mit und halt' das da dran.
So.
Wunderbar. Das ist ja auch nur ne kleine...
ne, ne Kleinigkeit. Sagen wir mal aus. Wunderbar.
Also. Flaschen hat funktioniert.
Einbinden in Home Assistant hat funktioniert.
Alles gut. Wunderbar. Tut.
Guck, jetzt kann ich meinen Fernseher,
also meinen Heizlüfter, da drüber ausschalten.
Und das Beste ist, dadurch,
dass ich das jetzt so ein bisschen ungefähr in die Richtung
kalibriert habe...
Jetzt haben wir eine Steckdose von vier, ne, die anderen wär' ich jetzt...
Jetzt weiß man ja, wie's funktioniert.
Aber was, was auch noch ganz cool ist,
was dadurch, dass ich jetzt die ganzen Infos habe
von dem... von dem Gerät,
kann ich zum Beispiel jetzt hier auch sagen, hey,
wenn mich
mein Stromverbrauch interessiert, da gibt's jetzt,
da gibt's jetzt was Neues. Also entweder
kann ich sowas hier machen,
wenn ich das, wenn ich das sehen will.
Das Motor...
Current...
Sonstwas. Und dann werdet ihr sehen,
wenn ich das jetzt, wenn ich das jetzt speicher,
und ich mach' den hier an,
dann geht das gleich rauf.
Oder auch nicht.
Ach, das ist schon three minutes ago.
Aber...
0,84 Ampere kann ja schlecht sein.
Was sagt das Motor
selbst? Das Motor sagt
vier.
Scheint sich nicht so schnell zu updaten.
She baited.
Ja, dann nicht.
Dann, dann nicht.
Das muss man sich ein bisschen genauer angucken.
Zumindest...
Komm, mal gucken, was es noch für Sachen
gibt, die man einstellen kann.
Wir machen nochmal an.
Ich glaub', der updatet sich wirklich
einfach nicht so schnell.
Ich mein', das stimmt, aber der Rest,
der Rest updatet sich irgendwie nicht so.
Das ist unsere, das ist meine Test
Home Assistant Installation.
Kannst du einstellen, wie schnell er sich updatet?
Ja. Alle fünf
Minuten?
Nee, nee, F5 guckt,
F5 bringt nix.
Alle fünf Minuten? Das ist ja nix.
Weißt du die Option dafür?
Zumindest, wir können
mal gucken, was wir sonst noch, was wir sonst noch so einstellen
können. Device Info.
Nee, mehr gibt's anscheinend gar nicht.
Mehr
gibt's anscheinend gar nicht.
Decreation.
Das Motor Firmware Version.
Oh, juckt mich nicht.
MQTT Count Last Restart Time.
Das Motor IP find ich immer sinnvoll,
die zu enablen, dass man
nachgucken kann, was für ein IP
das Ding hat.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Computer Option Update
MQTT
...
Keine Ahnung. Energy.
Was? Teleperiod?
Tele?
Per... Period?
Secure Value and Force
Publish State and Sensor Message.
Ah, Default. Okay, das ist tatsächlich
Teleperiod.
Also machen wir jetzt mal
Teleperiod 5.
Das sind halt alle 5 Sekunden.
So.
Hä?
She baited.
Ich sag 5.
Oder ist das einfach 10?
Wahrscheinlich ist 10 das Kleinste.
Maximal 10.
Ah, okay.
Also alle 10 Sekunden
updated jetzt.
Gut, das bedeutet jetzt ja auch,
wenn ich jetzt
einschalte, den Heizlüfter,
was man hier schon sieht,
dass das ziemlich rauf geht.
Ah.
So, und das Ganze kann ich jetzt
schön in mein Dashboard verbinden.
So, das Motor hat ein neues Feature.
Hat irgendwie ein Energy
Consumption Grid. Habe ich noch nie
verwendet. Ich mach den
Heizlüfter erstmal wieder aus.
Habe ich noch nie verwendet, aber könnten wir jetzt eigentlich
uns mal kurz anklicken. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was
das ist. Configure...
Configure Amount Energy Consume Grid.
Ach nee, das ist irgendwie
für
Solaranlage und sowas.
Next.
Solar Panels. Lol, weh, alter.
Das ist für Solar Panels.
Next, next. Battery System.
Next. Gas Consumption. Next.
Individual Devices.
Add Devices.
Das Motor. Hier.
Bam.
Total Energy. Safe.
Ja, super.
Das bringt mir ja gar nichts.
Das ist was
für Leute mit Solaranlagen
und sowas. Wo ich übrigens am überlegen bin, ob ich mir nicht
eine Solaranlage jetzt mal endlich aufs Dach mache.
Wollte mir demnächst einen von den Stadtwerken
bestellen, der mich mal berät. Ich weiß nicht,
wie gut die das können.
Aber das muss man echt sagen, das ist schon nice.
Easy Integration.
Home Assistant. Knopf gedrückt.
Lüfter im Bad geht an.
Und man sieht sogar den Stromverbrauch.
Wobei das jetzt
das falsche ist, um den Stromverbrauch
anzuzeigen.
Wir brauchen die aktuelle
Leistung.
Was ist das denn?
Das ist das Motor
Power. Energy Power.
Das brauchen wir.
Und jetzt. Bam.
Und jetzt sollte der gleich irgendwas
950 Watt oder so anzeigen.
Oder auch nicht.
Ah, jetzt.
Das ist doch richtig nice, oder?
Das ist doch richtig pock.
So, jetzt können wir vielleicht
ein bisschen was sinnvolles hier
einstellen. Wobei, was
wollen wir da großartig einstellen?
Maximum 1000? Keine Ahnung.
Ist
reichlich sinnlos, jetzt überhaupt
sich das anzeigen zu lassen.
Aber ist cool, dass das so einfach funktioniert.
Also das muss man den Jungs bei Home Assistant wirklich mal lassen.
Die Standard
Sachen fürs Dashboard sind optisch
und bedienungsmäßig wirklich gut gemacht.
So.
Jetzt haben wir unsere Huge
das Motor Steckdose eingebunden.
Ey, mach doch schon was her.
Die Info brauche ich jetzt nicht wirklich.
Ehrlich gesagt ist die Info relativ überflüssig,
dass man Heizluft der 922 Watt
gerade braucht, aber
why not?
Wie viel die Steckdose ab kann,
ist ne gute Frage.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die 10 oder 16
Ampere rated ist, aber was
die China-Chinesen so raten,
weiß ich nicht.
Guck mal mal.
Be smart.
Wenn die flashbar ist,
geht der Preis sogar halbwegs in Ordnung.
Specs?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Das steht wieder nicht da.
Seht ihr irgendwas? 16?
Ach hier, ja.
Dann müssten es 16 sein.
Oder?
Ist das 230 mal 16?
Was ist 230 mal 16?
Okay, das passt.
Ja, 16. Also sagen die China-Chinesen,
sagen 16 Ampere.
Ob das dann wirklich so ist?
Also ich würde da jetzt
nicht unbedingt noch
ne Steckdosenleiste mit 3 Heizlüftern
dranhängen.
Gut, wunderbar.
Ja, so funktioniert das.
So funktioniert das.
So macht man das.
China-Steckdosen,
China-Chinesen-Steckdosen
flashen.
Ich werd's mir jetzt sparen,
die anderen 3.
Hast du nen Affiliate-Link für AliExpress?
Nein, hab ich nicht.
Ich werd mir jetzt sparen,
die anderen 3 auch zu flashen,
weil die Katz geht mir schon auf den Keks.
Die steht schon vor der Tür und kratzt da dran rum.
Ich glaub, ich muss jetzt Schluss machen
und mich um meine Katz kümmern.
Aber ich hoffe, es hat euch trotzdem gefallen.
Mal wieder progress streamen.
Und wir haben eigentlich alles gemacht,
was wir machen wollten.
Kalibriert, MQTT Home Assistant-Integration,
Nexus Point.
Perfekt.
Also Leute, wo kann man die Go-Zone kaufen?
Kann man so nicht sagen.
Die Frage ist, ob man die Version noch kaufen kann,
die geflasht wird.
Irgendeine Idee, wen ich hosten kann,
wer macht denn?
YouTube, Battlefield,
was gibt's denn da gerade?
Nicht YouTube, Twitch.
Was haben wir denn für Battlefield-Streams?
Moment, Battlefield 2042? Nein.
Null.
Ach ja, Battlefield 3.
Just Dance.
Das hat äußerst viel mit Battlefield 3 zu tun,
muss ich sagen.
Story, 0w.
Tja.
Egal Leute, ich geh jetzt auf.
Macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Stream.
Gucken wir, wann das nächste Video kommt.
Nächstes Video ist eigentlich geplant,
aber vielleicht mach ich vorher noch
ein Stellenanzeigen-Video.
Je nachdem, was ich früher oder besser hinkriege.
Also wir sehen uns, Leute.
Bis dann, ich hoffe, euch hat's gefallen.
Tschüss.